GOOD MORNING THIS ON GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE THANK YOU --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE WITH US TODAY.
I'M JIM WOOD -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR THIS DISTRICT AND I'D LIKE
TO THINK -- I'M SORRY I WE ARE
YOU KNOW.
I THINK THAT I'M TECHNICALLY
CHALLENGED HERE SO I CAN TIE MY
SHOES SOME DAYS.
BUT NO I'D LIKE TO THINK MY
COLLEAGUE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER WHOSE --
THE CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES FROM
THIS HEARING TO EUREKA -- I SO
WE CAN PROBABLY -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHESBRO HERE CENTER
CHESBRO HERE -- AND HE MAY BE
ABLE TO ELABORATE ON THIS BUT
I'M NOT SURE THIS IS EVER
HAPPENED -- IN THIS COMMUNITY
BEFORE SO THIS IS THIS IS A THIS
IS A BIG DEAL. FOR US SO.
AND HE I ALSO APPRECIATE THAT MR
FOR TO ROUTE REALIZES IT'S A
LONG TRIP TO GET HERE -- AND IT
WHEN IT.
AND HIS STAFF -- FOR ALL THE
WORK TO PUT THIS TOGETHER TODAY.
I THANK YOU TO ALSO TO THE CITY
FOR USE OF THEIR CHAMBERS TODAY
AND THE REDWOOD KERR -- READ
COAST REGIONAL CENTER FOR
HELPING -- THEIR HELP IN MAKING
THIS HAPPEN AS WELL -- WE'RE
TODAY TO HEAR FROM YOU.
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES IN
YOUR FAMILY -- TO SPEAK DIRECTLY
TO US ABOUT WHAT THE STATE CAN
DO. TO TO TO MAKE YOUR
CHALLENGES A BIT EASIER.
WE HAVE SOME GREAT SUPPORT
SERVICES AND DEDICATED PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND HERE
LOCALLY.
OR ALREADY SUPPORTING YOU WAS
SERVICES BUT WE KNOW THERE MAY
BE OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMPROVEMENT.
SO I DON'T THINK AGAINST OF
MISTER FRAZIER FOR THE ACTING TO
VISIT THE NORTH COAST.
HERE -- FROM ONE OF THE
COMMUNITIES IN MY DISTRICT --
SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS A MOSTLY
RURAL AREA I'M ALWAYS GRATEFUL --
NGUYEN NE A COMMUNITIES I
REPRESENT GET ATTENTION SO.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO MISTER FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MEMBER.
ASSEMBLY WOULD.
I JUST LIKE TO HAVE BEEN
DISTRICTS HAS GROWN OPPORTUNITY --
TO HAVE A FEW WORDS AND I'M JUST
HONORED THAT HE'S HERE TODAY.
WELL I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
THE INVITATION TO SET UP YOUR
WITH YOUR EXCEL USED TO BE
SOMEBODY.
HERE THE GUYS IN THE CHAIRS NOW
AND AND I'M SO APPRECIATIVE.
AS OURS AND WOMEN IS OF OF YOU.
UP TO VISIT ARE NOT RURAL SPOT
THAT WE LOVE SO MUCH -- BUT I
ALSO WANT EXPRESS MY DEEP
GRATITUDE BECAUSE IN THE ENTIRE.
FOURTEEN YEARS I SPENT IN THE
STATES ASSEMBLY.
I TRIED TO GIVE THE BOTH THE
FAMILIES AND THE PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES VOICE.
BY CHAIRING THIS FIRST ON THE
SENATE SIDE THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE AND THEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE THERE
ARE SO MANY OTHER COMPETING
NEEDS THAT ARE VERY VALID.
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
SERVICES FOR SENIORS THINGS THAT.
HOW LARGE CONSTITUENCIES IN GOOD
WILL ORGANIZE LOBBIES -- AND
IT'S BUT IT THERE ISN'T AS GREAT
A VOICE.
OFTEN FOR THE DISABILITIES
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES AND SO
ANY CHAMPIONS THEY NEED
INDIVIDUAL PLEASE LISTEN WILL.
STAND UP AND CAUCUS AND SAY
DON'T FORGET ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT POPULATION AND SO
GIVES ME A LOT OF COMFORT NOW
THAT I THE REFEREE TO KNOW THAT
SOMEONE IS PROVIDING THE KIND.
THAT YOU ARE SO.
IS THAT YOU'VE COME TO YOU WE
CAN HOLD THIS HEARING.
I'M NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO STAY
FOR THE HEARINGS ON APOLOGIZE IN
ADVANCE BUT I AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR THE INVITATION TO JOIN.
APPEAR ON DAIS.
IT'S AN ABSOLUTE HONOR TO HAVE
YOU KNOW I WANT TO TELL.
THE FOLKS THAT ARE HERE TODAY
THAT WHEN WE WERE IN -- MISTER
JASPER LAST NIGHT OF SEXUALLY
CAME TO ME AND SAID.
I'M GOING TO PASS THE TORCH OFF
TO YOU.
AND MAKE SURE THAT YOU -- TWENTY
SUPPORTED THE ID POPULOUS.
AND I TOOK THAT TO HEART AND
WITH HIS MENTOR SHIP IN THIS.
FAITH.
I ALWAYS WHEN I SAW HIM TODAY
WAS JUST ABSOLUTE TREASURE -- SO --
HE'S THE REASON.
THE PURPOSEFUL REASONS WHY TODAY
TO ALSO.
WITH THAT GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE SO
EARLY ON A SATURDAY.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
PARTICIPATING THIS DURING THE
ASSEMBLY SOME SELECT COMMITTEE
OF THE INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
I WANT TO THANK.
YOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF MY TEAM
COLLEAGUES -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JIM WOOD. FOR INVITING US HERE
TO HOLD ITS HEARING IN RICA.
HIS STAFF FOR THE FINE JOB
HELPING SET THIS UP.
I WANT TO THANK MY STAFF
JENNIFER IN IT.
WE'RE HERE ON THEIR OWN TIME
SATURDAY -- WE'VE BEEN GOING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THESE
HEARINGS AND MY GIVES OF
THEMSELVES ALSO SELFLESSLY TO BE
ABLE TO OF THE ID POPULATION
ALSO I CAN'T THANK THEM ENOUGH.
HANNAH SPECIAL THANK YOU TO THE
CITY OF EUREKA FOR ALLOWING THE
USER CHAMBERS AND FOR ALL THE
TECHNICAL FOR THE CITY'S SOME OF
SOME.
OF THE SUPPORT US WITH.
AND THANK YOU TO RICK BLOOMBERG
EVERYONE AT RED BECAUSE REGIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUR HELP IN MAKING
THIS HEARING IS SUCCESS.
THIS HEARING BEING CREAM TO THE
SELECT COMMITTEE PAGE ON THE
STATE ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE AND MY
LOOK.
OF FACEBOOK PAGE LIKE ME ON
FACEBOOK [INAUDIBLE]
JUST SAN.
VIDEO OF THE ENTIRE HEARING WILL
BE ARCHIVED IN LINK THAT THE
SELECT COMMITTEES PAGE WITH
CLOSED CAPS.
VIDEO OF THE MOST.
OF MOST OF OUR PREVIOUS HEARINGS
OUR GUIDANCE SELECT COMMITTEE
PAGE AS WELL.
AS WELL AS FUTURE HEARINGS WILL
BE ALL.
NOW LET'S GET TO THIS HEARING.
I'M A MEMBER JIM FRAZIER I
REPRESENT THE ELEVENTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT.
THE DELTA REGION.
BUT I'M HERE TODAY.
THIS COMMITTEE AND HELPING THE
COMMUNITY GETS A SPORTING
DESERVES FROM THE STATE AS IS A
PASSION FOR ME.
WE ARE NOT HERE.
CHAU SHOWCASE HERSELF WE ARE
HERE TO LISTEN TO YOU.
WE ARE HERE TO DISCUSS THE
CHALLENGES FACED BY FAMILIES WHO
LIVE INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
I DE AFFECTS ALL OF US
REGARDLESS OF OUR BACKGROUND OR
WHERE WE DO LIVE.
R. IDG POPULATION CONTINUES TO
GROW AND WE MUST PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES SUPPORT WIDE
IDT FRIENDS.
NEIGHBORS AND OUR FAMILY MEMBERS.
AT THE CAPITOL WE DON'T HEAR
FROM YOU AS MUCH AS I WE'D LIKE.
SO WE BROUGHT THE COMMITTEE TO
YOU.
SELECT COMMITTEES ARE DIFFERENT
FROM STANDING LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEES.
WE DON'T HOLD HEARINGS ON
PENDING LEGISLATION THE
LEGISLATION COULD HAPPEN.
IF YOUR INPUT AND OFTEN DOES.
I THINK I'M CARRYING TWELVE
BILLS THIS YEAR. FOR THE ID
POPULATION ALL DERIVED FROM OUR
HEARINGS.
WE LEARN FROM PREVIOUS HEARINGS
THAT LISTEN TO YOUR STORIES IS
THE MOST VALUABLE THING WE'RE
GOING TO DO.
WE HAVE SET ASIDE AMPLE TIME AT
THE END OF THE HEARING FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT TO HEAR FROM YOU.
YOU HAVE A FULL AGENDA.
SO LET'S GET THIS PARTY STARTED.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH PRESENT BRIEF
PRESENTATIONS BY STAFF THAT
WOULD COAST REGIONAL CENTER
BEGINNING WITH EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR RICK BLOOMBERG AND
BOARD PRESIDENT STEEP.
PRESS PLEASE GENTLEMAN.
YOU READY PLEASE PROCEED THANK.
YOU [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
I'M NOT QUITE SURE HOW.
AND OKAY SO THE THING IS.
SHARE.
WELL THIS IS VERY INTIMIDATING --
WITH THE WITH THE CAMERAS AND
I'D FIRST LIKE -- TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMAN WORD IN THIS MOMENT
FRASER FOR CONDUCTING.
ON THIS MEETING -- AND IT.
A NEW FOR US TO COME.
AS A COMMUNITY AND TALK ABOUT
THE GOOD THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING AS WELL AS SOME OF THE
CHANNEL -- I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR COMING HERE THIS MORNING.
I'D LIKE TO WISH A HAPPY
MOTHER'S DAY ON TO ANY OF THE
MOTHERS THAT ARE.
IN THE AUDIENCE -- DOCTORATE
LUMBER I HAVE THE HONOR TO BE
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
REDWOOD COAST REGIONAL CENTER.
DON AND BE HERE WITH OUR OUR
BOARD PRESIDENT TO PRESS.
ON IN LARGE QUANTITIES STAFF.
SOME ARE ON BOARD MEMBERS.
AND OUR CLIENTS -- I'M NOT GOING
TO GO THROUGH MY WHOLE
PRESENTATION MORNING IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME -- BUT I WOULD
LIKE.
TO MAKE A FEW POINTS TODAY THAT
I THINK ARE IMPORTANT IN THE
MAIL GEN POINTS YOU'VE HEARD AND
PLACES IN THE STATE
.
SOME.
OTHER FOLKS ARE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT ON THE REALLY GOOD THINGS.
HAPPENING IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT.
YOUR CHALLENGE -- AND WHAT IS IN
THE AREA OF RISK COORDINATION.
PROBABLY NO YOUR RECORD.
IN THIS SURVEY.
ON ARE JUST.
IN.
THIS EXCERPT OF TO PROVIDE
RESPONSES.
THIS IS A SUSTAINABLE.
REDWOOD BECAUSE THERE IS NO
[INAUDIBLE]
FUNDED.
MANDATED.
RATE GOES.
UP.
WE DON'T.
REAL MONSTERS SERVICE NATION.
FUNDED FOR ABOUT 65%.
OF THE COST [INAUDIBLE]
AN ENTERTAINING.
PART OF THE PROBLEM [INAUDIBLE]
FORMULA [INAUDIBLE]
UNDER.
FOUR IF YOU HAVE [INAUDIBLE]
THE WORKING.
ANOTHER WHICH IF YOU HAVE SO
MANY PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE SERVING
IN YOUR REGIONAL CENTER YOU GET
SO MANY SERVICE COORDINATORS.
WITH THAT AND CAPTURE THE
REALITY OF PROVIDING SERVICES IN
OUR FOR RURAL COUNTIES.
AND LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
IF A FAMILY WANTS TO BRING THEIR
CHILD. TO A SPECIALIZED META
SERVICE SAY SOMETHING LIKE NOR A
TREE.
WELL.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT.
SO WE HAVE TO ARRANGE TO
TRANSPORT ON THAT FAMILY.
ON TO SAN FRANCISCO SACRAMENTO.
SO WE HAVE.
TO TRAVEL WE HAVE TO ARRANGE.
FOR HOTEL ACCOMMODATE.
WE MAY HAVE TO ARRANGE.
THE PANEL FUELS [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
A GROUP [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH BUT YEAH.
YEAH.
IF WE WILL.
DO THE TEST [INAUDIBLE]
IT'S TRUE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO -- AS LONG AS WE USE THIS.
IS A PER CAPITA FUNDING FOR ANA
WE WON'T HAVE ENOUGH SERVICE
COORDINATORS TO BE A TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN.
OUR WORLD FOR THESE -- YOU
TRAVELED UP HERE -- IS A
BEAUTIFUL PLACE TO LIVE -- BUT
IT TAKES TIME TO GET FROM ONE
PLACE TO ANOTHER.
SO NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
THE OTHER THING THAT I WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT THIS MORNING WAS THE
NEEDS OF OUR SERVICE PROVIDER
COMMUNITY -- BECAUSE OF SOME --
AND WE'RE WORKING MALTA
[INAUDIBLE]
NO WHICH WORKS REALLY WELL
OUR SERVICE.
APPLE BUT I'LL GIVE YOU.
AN ASTUTE DURING THE REDWOOD
THANKS FOR THIS.
LONG DAYS SEVEN DAYS WE WITH OUR
TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE.
I NEEDED.
TO OKAY.
LOCATED TO ANOTHER AREA
[INAUDIBLE]
WAITING [INAUDIBLE]
THAT. TO DO WELL THEY WERE REAL.
TRY TO KEEP THE LEVEL OF MOTHER.
AND THEN THE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
AS YOU KNOW FOR OUR SERVICE
PROVIDERS ARE JUST NOT
COMPETITIVE.
ON THEY'RE NOT COMPETITIVE WITH
FAST FOOD THEY'RE NOT
COMPETITIVE WAS WAS RETAIL.
AND THE SKILL SET THAT OUR
PROVIDERS -- IS IS LARGE ON
THEY'RE DOING IMPORTANT WORK.
ON SOMETIMES A DEALING WITH
PEOPLE WAS VERY COMPLEX NEEDS.
ON THE LEVEL OF TRAINING THAT IS
REQUIRED IS HIGH AND WE AND WE
WANT TO BE HIGHER -- SO -- WE
NEED.
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THOSE
RATES AND WE NEED TO DO IT SOON.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT THE
RATES THAT WERE ABLE TO PAY
SERVICE PROVIDERS MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR US TO ATTRACT
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO OUR AREA --
AND WE NEED WE NEED MORE
SERVICES TO BE A WOULD BE ABLE
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE FOLKS
THAT WE SERVE [INAUDIBLE] FOR
THE IN THE LAST POINT DR PHONE
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE AN UNKNOWN
THEN I'LL SHUT UP.
ON IS.
THE I THINK WE REALLY NEED TO
MAKE.
MUCH MORE -- BUT ENTER ENTER.
TOM WE LEARN FROM OUR RICHER
THAN ON A DRUG.
THAT IF JENNER HI [INAUDIBLE]
RIGHT.
NO. TO THOSE THAT WE KNOW.
RATES OF DUAL DIAGNOSED THIS.
THE I. D. D. POPULATION.
SO WE CAN IDENTIFY THESE KIDS
EARLY WE KNOW THE RIGHT THINGS
TO DO AND IF WE IF WE CAN INVEST
IN THIS EARLY INTERVENTION WE
CAN CHANGE THEIR LIVES.
WE CAN KEEP FAMILY STRONG WE CAN
KEEP FAMILIES TOGETHER.
ON END.
THE BOTTOM LINE -- IN TERMS OF
OUR TAX DOLLARS IN OUR RESOURCES
IS THAT THIS EARLY INTERVENTION
IS.
MUCH LESS EXPENSIVE IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO BUT IT'S MUCH
LESS EXPENSIVE THAN WAITING TO
LATER ON WHEN WE HAVE.
TO DEVELOP -- LOCKED FACILITIES
ON ME AND OTHER INTERVENTIONS
THAT ARE EXPENSIVE AND AND
HARMFUL FRANKLY TO THE PEOPLE WE
SERVE.
SOON THAT'S ALL I'VE GOT TO SAY
ON THAT.
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING.
LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO US
DEPRESS OUR PORT PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR A
LISTENING TO US IT'S DEEPLY
DEEPLY APPRECIATED.
THE PRESENCE OF SENATE WHICH HAS
BROUGHT TAKES ME BACK TO THE
NUMBER OF YEARS TWENTY YEARS AGO.
MY GRANDDAUGHTER WAS BORN WITH
CEREBRAL PALSY.
IT WAS.
AS A RESULT OF THAT EVENT THAT I
BECAME INVOLVED WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTER BECAME
[INAUDIBLE]
PRESIDENT DONALD [INAUDIBLE]
INCLUDED.
I'M OFF BECAUSE I TRULY BELIEVE
THAT NEW IDEAS IN.
A NEW GENERATION OF LEADERSHIP.
FROM WITHIN THE COMMUNITY NEEDED
COME FORWARD.
AND BEGIN TO TAKE HOLD OF THE
REINS AND GUIDE AND DIRECT
ACCORDING TO THE VALUES OF EACH
AND EVERYONE OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES WHICH IS THE QUORUM.
REGIONAL CENTER WARTS.
I I RETURNED ON THE BASIS TO
SERVE AGAIN.
AND I WAS STRUCK BY.
THE REPEAT OF INSTITUTIONAL
HISTORY.
AND I SAY THIS AND I WANT
EVERYBODY IN THE AUDIENCE TO
UNDERSTAND THIS.
MEMBERS SENATOR WEST HAS BRO AN
ASSEMBLY PERSON PATTY BURKE.
OUR SYSTEM WOULD HAVE SUFFERED
GREATLY BACK IN THOSE YEARS WHEN
WE'RE GOING THROUGH A HUGE
BUDGET CUTS.
WAY BACK THEN TO THAT.
BUSINESS MANAGER PELICAN BAY
STATE PRISON AND WE WERE GOING
THROUGH THE 10% REDUCTION PLANS
THAT BECAME REALITIES.
WITHIN TWO OR THREE MONTHS AFTER
SUBMITTING THEM SO I UNDERSTAND
VERY CLEARLY.
WHAT WAS HAPPENING WITHIN THE
STATE AND AT THE SAME TIME HOW
THAT WAS OF THE?
OUR ABILITY TO SERVE.
CONSUMERS CLIENTS BACK IN THOSE
DAYS AND AGAIN AFTER.
THIS TIME OFF.
WE FIND OURSELVES.
BACK IN THE SAME CIRCUMSTANCE OF
TRYING TO CATCH UP.
IN AN APPRECIATE THAT.
WHAT I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
THOUGH IS THE IMPORTANCE OF I
THINK FUTURE PLANNING?
THIS IS A VERY UNIQUE
COLLABORATION.
VERY UNIQUE I'M NOT SURE THAT.
THERE IS ANOTHER KIND OF
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA.
BETWEEN THE CLIENTS AND
CONSUMERS THAT ARE SERVED.
BY THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM
THE WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND THE
INVESTMENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
STATE LEGISLATURES MAKING.
ITS UNIQUE MY CONCERN WHEN I SEE
WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
IS WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE TWENTY
YEARS FROM NOW. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES ARE WE GOING TO FACE.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE EACH AND EVERY
ONE OF US HERE TO THINK ABOUT.
THAT SYSTEM IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE I WOULD DARE SAY EVEN TO
INVEST.
IN FUTURE US. TO STUDY.
THE BEST MINDS IN A POSSIBLE
WITHIN THE STATE AND MAYBE
THROUGH IN THE COUNTRY AS WELL.
AS WELL IS THE DIRECTION OF
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES GOING
TO LOOK LIKE.
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE
FUTURE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES WHAT'S OUT THERE IN
TERMS OF TECHNOLOGY WHICH ON THE
CUTTING EDGE OF MEDICINE AND?
MOST IMPORTANT IS TO BRING A
MESSAGE BACK TO THE CITIZENS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
TRUSTING US TO DO THE BEST THAT
WE POSSIBLY CAN. FOR THE CLIENTS.
I FEAR EXHAUSTION.
I FEAR EXHAUSTION OF THE GOOD
WILL OF THE TAXPAYERS OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE MUST CONTINUE TO HAVE A
VISION NOT JUST IN TERMS OF
RESPONDING TO WHAT IS
IMMEDIATELY PRESENT.
WHAT DOES THE FUTURE HOLD?
WHAT IS IT US?
WHAT IS IT?
GOING TO BE TO FAMILIES TO
CLIENTS.
I SHARE THIS WITH PASSION
BECAUSE AFTER TWENTY YEARS.
I STILL SEE.
THE STRUGGLE [INAUDIBLE]
SUSTAIN.
WE STRUGGLE TO SUSTAIN WE FIND
OURSELVES SATISFIED WITH.
QUINCY. ONE ADVOCACY.
I WANT COMPETENCE.
THE DELIVERY OF SERVICES.
BY PROFESSIONAL MEN AND WOMEN.
THE SUPPORT OF OF THE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE CITY
CALIFORNIA.
REALIZING THAT THERE IS A VISION
THAT WE HAVE FOR TOMORROW.
IT'S WORTH THEIR INVESTMENT
THROUGH THEIR TAX DOLLARS.
PLEASE I WOULD ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER.
IN ALL OF THESE DISCUSSIONS I
DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY'S BROUGHT
TO ABOUT TO YOU THE NEED. TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS
BUT I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
EQUAL COLLABORATIVE EFFORT ON
THE PART OF REGIONAL CENTERS.
ON THE PART OF ARCA ON THE PART
OF THE DEPARTMENT.
THE LEGISLATURE FOR US TO SIT
DOWN WITH SOME THE BEST MINDS
AND FIGURE OUT WHAT IS A SYSTEM
GOING TO LOOK LIKE IN TWENTY
YEARS WHAT'S GOING TO COST US.
MY GRANDDAUGHTER KAITLYN WILL BE
FORTY YEARS OLD.
WHAT WILL BE THERE FOR HER?
AGAIN I JUST WANT TO PERSONALLY
THANK ALL OF YOU ESPECIALLY
CENTER CHESBRO.
YOU WERE THE LIGHT FOR US SIR.
YOU WILL NEVER BE FORGOTTEN
[INAUDIBLE]
WELL SAID.
AND HE WILL NEVER BE FORGOTTEN.
SO NO WILL MOVE ON TO KIM NASH
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY SERVICE
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU [INAUDIBLE]
PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING HERE TO OUR AREA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOU.
CAN SEE WITH DENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT NEEDS I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW MUCH THAT AFFECTS THE
WELLNESS OF EVERYBODY IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
ASSEMBLYMAN FRAZIER THANK YOU
FOR ARE ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
MOVING FORWARD ON BEHALF OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND TO BE HERE TO
HEAR WHAT WE SEE OUR NEEDS AS
WELL AS WHAT'S WORKING SO WE CAN
SHARE THOSE HIGHLIGHTS AS WELL.
AND OF COURSE SENATOR CHARLES
BRO IT IS ALWAYS WONDERFUL TO
SEE YOU AND SEE YOU CONTINUING
TO BE A CHAMPION NOT ONLY FOR
OUR AREA.
BUT AS WELL FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
AND JENNIFER THANK YOU FOR
PUTTING US ALL TOGETHER FOR US.
WORK QUITE A BIT TO ORGANIZE.
SOMEONE HERE TO TALK ABOUT OUR
EFFORTS GOING FORWARD WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- AS WE KNOW
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
HOUSING PRICES ARE PRETTY
EXTRAORDINARY.
CURRENTLY MOST INDIVIDUALS IN
OUR SERVICE SYSTEM PEOPLE OF
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ARE.
DESPERATELY LOOKING FOR WORK
THROUGH OUR EMPLOYMENT FIRST
INITIATIVE AND THEY'LL BE SOME
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT.
BUT IN ADDITION THAT THEY HAVE
SAFE.
UNIVERSALLY DESIGNED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
MOST OF THEIR INCOME IS FROM
SUPPLEMENTAL SOCIAL SECURITY
SOMEWHERE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
NINE HUNDRED AND SIXTY DOLLARS A
MONTH.
THE FAIR MARKET RENTS IN OUR
AREA ARE VERY RURAL AREA.
A RUNNY ONE BEDROOM SOMEWHERE IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY DOLLARS A
MONTH.
THAT LEAVES MANY PEOPLE OF MANY
ADULTS WITH ONLY TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS LEFT OVER EACH MONTH TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO PAY
[INAUDIBLE]
FOR TRANSPORTATION.
MEDICAL BENEFITS.
AND VARIOUS OTHER FOOD AND
RELATED EXPENSES.
WE HAVE STARTED OUR INITIATIVES
IN WORKING WITH THE WORLD
COMMUNITY HOUSING IN A LOCAL.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER.
WE THANK YOU FOR OUR SUPPORTING
AND APPROVING VARIOUS --
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DEVELOPMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND WE WOULD
ASK THAT THAT CONTINUE.
OUR GOAL IS TO DEVELOP THOSE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IN
EVERY COUNTY FOR THAT WHICH WE
WORK WITH.
CURRENTLY WE ARE WORKING ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF ONE PARTICULAR
AREA FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
MULTI FAMILY.
IN WHICH WE WOULD HAVE BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT UP TO TEN PEOPLE IN.
HOUSING THAT MEETS ONLY 30% OF
THEIR INCOME.
WHICH QUALIFIES FOR TO BE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT IT'S
CLOSE TO TRANSPORTATION AND THAT
IT IS FULLY ACCESSIBLE
REGARDLESS OF SOMEBODY'S
PHYSICAL ABILITIES TO ACCESS
THEIR DWELLING.
THIS IS VERY DIFFICULT WORK IN
ORDER TO PARTNER WITH MANY OF
THE DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND
REPRESENTATIONS THROUGH OUR
COMMUNITY TO LOOK AT THESE
DEVELOPMENTS.
THAT'S EXPENSE UP. TO DEVELOP
MULTI HOUSE A MULTI UNIT
DWELLING IS EXPENSIVE AND WE ARE.
LUCKY TO HAVE THE PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH.
WORKING WITH OUR LOCAL VETERANS
SO THAT WE CAN POOL OUR MONEY
TOGETHER AND POOL DEVELOPMENT
MONEY TOGETHER TO APPLY FOR TAX
CREDITS TO GET THESE
DEVELOPMENTS IN.
IN PLACE.
THAT BEING SAID.
WE WANTED TO CONTINUE TO URGE
THAT THE SUPPORT OF ADDITIONAL
FUNDING ADDITIONAL BILLS A DIFF
TIONAL TAX CREDITS WHERE THEY
MAY BE. TO CONTINUE OUR
DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS FOR THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WE DO HAVE SOME BROCHURES ARE
REGARDING SOME OF OUR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING EFFORTS WITH OUR
DEVELOPER WHO IS A NOT FOR
PROFIT -- TO EXPAND THAT WE
WOULD LEAVE WITH YOU FOR YOU TO
LOOK AT MOVING FORWARD WE WANTED
TO BE ABLE -- TO SHARE THE
IMPORTANCE OF EMPLOYMENT AND HOW
THAT.
CONNECTS WITH HOUSING WHEN WE
HAVE SAFE AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE
CAN HELP EXPAND.
INTEGRATIVE COMPACT COMPLAINANT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME.
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
THANK YOU VERY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH C<C.CYAN> I SO I JUST ALSO WANT</C>
TO AND I PRIMARY MISTER I'M NOT
VERY GOOD BUT I WANT TO
INTRODUCE AND AND THANKS. FOR
BEING HERE SUPERVISOR -- REX
BONE.
AND SUPERVISOR VIRGIN BASS FOR
BEING HERE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE LISTENING WITH US
THIS MORNING.
DID I MISS ANYBODY ELSE.
GOOD I'M GLAD THAT'S A THAT'S A
FIRST SO.
IT'S REALLY WEIRD TO BE ON THE
PODIUM IN WHICH I CAN SEEK OUT
WITHOUT HAVING TO STEP ON A
STOOL SO.
THAT SUPER THRILLING -- SO MY
NAME IS CHRIS MILLER AND I AM
THE CLIENT ADVOCATE AT REDWOOD
COAST REGIONAL CENTER.
I'VE HELD THAT POSITION FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS NOW.
AND HAVE MET.
UP WESLEY CHESBRO SEVERAL
SEVERAL TIMES.
AND ALWAYS ENJOY THAT
OPPORTUNITY -- IT'S IT'S
INTERESTING TO STAND UP HERE
BECAUSE I AM ALSO A PERSON WITH
A DISABILITY WHO RECEIVE
SERVICES. TO I HAVE CEREBRAL
PALSY AND DOT JUST A REALLY FUN
LIFE EXPERIENCE IN CASE ANY OF
YOU WHERE WONDERING -- AND MY
GLASSES ARE NOT WORKING VERY
WELL TODAY SAID THAT SUPER.
BUT PART OF THE REASON WHY I GOT
INTO A WORKING REDWOOD COAST
REGIONAL CENTER.
IS BECAUSE I WANTED TO WORK WITH
IN THE COMMUNITY IN WHICH I'M
ALSO A PART OF BECAUSE I FELT
THAT IF I CAN.
DO WITH THAT IF I GET INTO THIS
WORK AND CAN YOU KNOW.
DO SOMETHING THAT MATTERS THAT I
WOULD BE HELPING EVERYBODY KIND
OF SUCCEED AND WHEN WE ALL
SUCCEED THAT'S A REALLY GREAT
THING RIGHT.
SO PART OF MY ROLE IT REDWOOD
COAST IS TO GO IN TO SCHOOLS AND
TALKED TO STUDENTS WHO ARE WITH
DISABILITIES WHO ARE
TRANSITIONING OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT NOT AND TALK
THEM ABOUT.
FURTHERING EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES FURTHERING
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
KIND OF FIGURING OUT WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO.
BUT IN ALL MY YEARS AND DOING
THAT I'VE NOTICED SOME BARRIERS.
SO.
YOU ALL GO TO SCHOOL AND PEOPLE
ASK YOU WHAT YOU WANT TO DO WITH
YOUR LIVES AND YOU WANTED TO DO
WHEN YOU GREW UP AND I'M SURE
WESLEY CHESBRO SAID I WANT TO BE
A STATE ASSEMBLY MAN AND THEN A
SET.
A SENATOR I'M SURE THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED.
SO.
WHAT HAPPENS THOUGH WON'T YOU
GUYS GET THAT EXPERIENCE PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES DON'T OFTEN?
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES DON'T
GET TO HAVE THE LAKE.
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO WITH THEIR LIVES SO
I'D GO INTO SCHOOLS AND THOSE
CONVERSATIONS HAVE STARTED TO
HAPPEN.
BUT THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
ANSWER YES.
THEY HAVE NO Y. DE I AM THAT IS
REALLY WEIRD BECAUSE I THINK THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM SHOULD BE STARTING
PLANNING EARLIER WE SHOULD BE
GIVING PEOPLE MORE SUPPORT.
EDUCATION AND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES SO THAT THEY
BETTER THEY ARE LIFE EXPERIENCE
AND I THINK THAT LIKE EVERYBODY
DESERVES THE RIGHT TO EDUCATION
AND EMPLOYMENT REGARDLESS OF
DISABILITY OR NOT -- THE THINGS
THAT I ALSO.
TEND TO DO IS GO IN -- TO IS GO.
SORRY I SKIPPED AHEAD OF MYSELF
ANOTHER BARRIER THAT I SEE IS
THAT WE HAVE WHEN LOOKING FOR
EMPLOYMENT FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WE HAVE SOMEWHAT OF
A EMPLOYER BIAS.
THEY ASSUME THAT BECAUSE
SOMEBODY HAS A DISABILITY THAT
THEY ARE INCAPABLE OF DOING SOME
JOB OR BECAUSE SOMEBODY MIGHT
HAVE SOME KIND OF INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY.
AND CAPABLE OF DOING SOME TO ARM
I STAND UP HERE BEING ABLE TO
TALK TO ALL OF YOU.
BUT I HAVE.
I KNOW THAT THE THINGS HAPPEN
BECAUSE IN VARIOUS STAGES
THEY'VE HAPPENED TO ME YOU HAVE
NO IDEA HOW MANY OF MY FRIENDS
PEOPLE MISTAKE FOR MY YOU KNOW
SUPPORT PERSON.
AND SPEAK TO THEM INSTEAD OF ME
THAT'S REALLY INTERESTING I FIND
THAT ENTERTAINING -- BUT IT'S
IT'S A REALLY IT'S A REALLY KIND
OF WEIRD EXPERIENCE BECOME THERE
IS AN EMPLOYER BIAS BUT WHAT
EMPLOYERS.
DON'T UNDERSTAND IS HOW HIRING
SOMEBODY WITH A DISABILITY NOT
ONLY ADDS TO JUST THE FACT THAT
THEY ARE VERY NICE PEOPLE AND
GOOD FOR THEM BUT IT ADDS TO THE
DIVERSITY.
THE CULTURE AND THE PRODUCTIVITY
OF THAT BUSINESS AND THAT
CREATES REVENUE.
AND OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT
BUSINESS TO GROW.
YOU KNOW SO I I SEE THAT AS
BEING A MAJOR PROBLEM -- UNDER
THAT THE ACT I DO A COUPLE
THINGS BOTH LOCALLY AND
STATEWIDE -- AS WELL AS GOING
INTO SCHOOLS AND TALKING TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRANSITIONING FOR
WORK OR EDUCATION I TALKED TO
YOUNGER STUDENTS AND PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY ABOUT DISABILITY
AWARENESS.
AND DISABILITY VISIBILITY WHICH
I THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
LOOK LIKE I UNDERSTAND THAT WE
DO WE TEST.
AND WE TAKE.
YOU KNOW A PART IN THE GREATER
WHOLE OF THE WORLD -- HEY AND
YOU WOULD THINK THAT I WOULD
HAVE TO DO THINGS LIKE THAT BUT
I DEALS -- BUT I DO IT I TALK
ABOUT DISABILITY WEARING MASKS
AM I ALSO HAVE -- GO AND HAVE
BEEN DOING STATE AND LOCAL
ADVOCACY ON EMPLOYMENT AND
EDUCATION AND DEVELOPING YOU
KNOW EMPLOYMENT AND EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND I THINK THAT
THE VERY IMPORTANT SO I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU. TO PLEASE HELP ME
IN THAT TASK WHEREVER YOU CAN.
AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN
IT OVER TO SIERRA BROWN'S TO
TALK ABOUT THE EMPLOYMENT FAKED
INITIATIVE ARE YOU SEE I SEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I JUST WANNA SAY YOU'RE AMAZING.
TO LOOK AT ACTUALLY.
GOOD MORNING.
I'M SIERRA BRAGS I AM THE CMS
WAIVER AND EMPLOYMENT SPECIALIST
MANAGER IT RIGHT BECAUSE
REGIONAL CENTER FOR HUMBLE AND
DOWN COUNTIES.
AND I AM REALLY EXCITED TO TALK
WITH YOU GUYS ABOUT OUR
EMPLOYMENT FIRST INITIATIVE THIS
MORNING -- BUT FIRST I JUST WANT
TO RECOGNIZE -- THIS HISTORIC
MOMENT THAT IN BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S HOW WE GOT HERE -- YOU KNOW
OUR THIS CINEMA DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER OUR STATE INSTITUTION
CLOSED IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND I THINK.
YOU KNOW THAT IS.
AND I WANT TO RECOGNIZE NOT ONLY
THE WORK THAT OUR LEGISLATURE
HAS DONE FOR THAT BUT THAT SELF
ADVOCATES LIKE CHRIS MILLER AND
MANY OTHERS IN THIS ROOM.
I'M SAYING YOU KNOW WE DESERVE
WE DESERVE A LIFE LIKE ANYBODY
ELSE AND SO -- I THINK THAT'S
JUST.
ME ONE OF THE MOST EXCITING
THINGS -- AND SO IT GOES HAND IN
HAND WITH EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE AS
WE ARE LOOKING AT SUPPORTING
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES TO
HAVE MEANINGFUL LIVES YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT MOST
WORKING AGE ADULTS STILL IS.
WE WORK AND SO GOING ALONG WITH
WHAT CHRIS WAS SAYING ABOUT
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH
KIDDOS EARLY ABOUT WHAT DO YOU
DO WHEN YOU GROW UP JUST LIKE WE
TALKED WITH MANY OTHER TYPICALLY
DEVELOPING CHILD -- THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE PROMOTING
AS PART OF OUR EMPLOYMENT FIRST
POLICY AND EMPLOYMENT FIRST IS
THIS IDEA THAT YOU KNOW THE VERY
FIRST OPTION THAT WE SHOULD GIVE
WORKING AGE ADULTS.
ON WHEN WE DO OUR INDIVIDUAL
PROGRAM PLAN IS.
DO YOU WANT TO WORK IF YOU DO
WANT TO WORK WHAT KIND OF WORK
DO YOU WANT TO DO AND HOW CAN
REGIONAL CENTER SUPPORT YOU TO
DO THAT WORK AND TO DO IT WELL.
AND SO THAT'S THAT'S A LITTLE
BIT OF A SHIFT FOR US AND SO
THAT'S A PART OF OUR EMPLOYMENT
FIRST POLICY IS TALKING WITH
THOSE KIDDOS EARLY AND THEN AS
THEY REACH ADULTHOOD.
PUTTING THE SUPPORTS IN PLACE
FOR PEOPLE TO WORK AND THAT'S
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
I'M ANOTHER CENTRAL COMPONENT OF
OUR EMPLOYMENT FIRST POLICY IS
COLLABORATION BECAUSE THERE IS
IT'S NOT POSSIBLE FOR US TO DO
EMPLOYMENT ALONE AND WE HAVE TO
BE PARTNERING WITH OUR BUSINESS
COMMUNITY LIKE CHRIS SIDE SO
THAT WE CAN -- REALLY DO SOME
AWARENESS WITH THEM AROUND AND
STATEMENT THAT THEY MAY HAVE
IMPLICIT BIAS THAT THEY MAY HAVE
AGAINST PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AND THEY MAY NOT EVEN REALIZE IT --
WE NEED TO PARTNER WITH OUR
DEPARTMENT OF REHAB THEY ARE THE
EXPERTS IN -- EMPLOYMENT -- FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WE ARE
PARTNERING WITH OUR SCHOOLS AND
AND OUR WORK ABILITY IN
TRANSITION PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS
AND OF COURSE WE'RE PARTNERING
WITH THE PEOPLE THAT WE SERVE.
THEIR FAMILIES AND OUR SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND SO WORKING
TOGETHER WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW IS
OUR COMMUNITY ORGANIZED AND WHAT
DO WE NEED TO DO DIFFERENTLY OR
BETTER SO THAT WE CAN HAVE WELL
SEQUENCE FUNDING TO SUPPORT
PEOPLE TO WORK -- AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
THROUGH OUR LOCAL PARTNERSHIP
AGREEMENTS WHICH FOR YOU KNOW
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA BLUEPRINT
FOR INTEGRATED COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT.
AND SO WE HAVE BEEN IN MENDOCINO
COUNTY LAST YEAR WE SIGNED OUR
FIRST LOCAL PARTNERSHIP
AGREEMENT BETWEEN REGIONAL
CENTER MENDOCINO CELL BY AND
DEPARTMENT OF REHAB AND SO
THEY'VE ALREADY BEEN
IMPLEMENTING.
WHAT WERE CAUGHT YOU KNOW WE
CALDWELL SEQUENCE FUNDING YOU
KNOW HERE IN HIGH SCHOOL YOU'RE
LEAVING THERE'S NO CLIFF IT'S
JUST A SEAMLESS TRANSITION FOR
THE PERSON?
IT ALL GOES WELL.
AND WE ARE ROLLING OUT OUR LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP HERE IN HUMBOLDT WE
EXPECT TO HAVE THAT SIGNED BY
THE END OF THIS YEAR.
AND WE'RE JUST GETTING STARTED
IN DOWN THERE WE SORT OF HAD OUR
FIRST MEETING GREAT GET TO KNOW
YOU LAST WEEK AND THEN I'M IN
LATE CLOUT COUNTY THEY'VE HAD
SEVERAL.
GET TO KNOW USING THEY'VE DONE
SEVERAL THINGS TOGETHER AND SO
THEY'RE GETTING WORK GETTING
WORKING THEIR LOCAL PARTNERSHIP
AGREEMENT TAIL.
ON THANKS AS WE ARE GROWING
RIGHT WE CONTINUE TO SERVE MORE
MORE PEOPLE AT REBEL BECAUSE WE
NOW SERVE OVER.
FOUR THOUSAND INCREASE IN THE
LAST [INAUDIBLE]
AS WE PEOPLE IN THE SHOW ME THE
MONEY DEFINING NINETY THREE
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE SAYING
CAN I HAVE A AN ART IN SO WE DO
HAVE A WONDERFUL SERVICE
PROVIDERS MANY OF THEM IN THIS
ROOM.
WHO ARE ABLE TO SUPPORT PEOPLE
IN THEIR HOPES AND DREAMS RIGHT
IN WHATEVER IT IS THAT THEY WANT
TO DEAL -- BUT THE CAPACITY WE
DO NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY I AM
CONSTANTLY HEARING FROM YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO WORK AND THEN
I'M LOOKING I'M CALLING OUR
PROVIDERS AND SEEING IS THERE A
PLACE FOR PEOPLE -- TO CERTAIN
THEM AND SO IN THERE THERE'S
JUST WE JUST DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
AND THAT'S IN PART BECAUSE IT'S
ANY IT'S A UNIQUE SKILL SET TO
DO WHAT WE CALL JOB DEVELOPMENT
FINDING A PLACE. TO WORK AND
TEACHING THAT EMPLOYER ABOUT.
YOU KNOW STIGMA CAM AND
ACCOMMODATIONS AND THEN ALSO --
PROVIDING ON THE JOB COACHING
FOR THAT PERSON WHO WANTS TO
WORK AND SO WE ARE WORKING WITH
OUR SERVICE PROVIDERS TO BRING
TRAININGS HERE -- TO DO MORE --
RATING FOR THE WORK FORCE TO
LEARN HOW TO DO JOB DEVELOPMENT
AND JOB COACHING -- BUT TO
SUSTAIN NETWORK FIRST WE ALSO
NEED TO SINGLE RATES WE NEED
PEOPLE ONCE THEY'RE TRAINED TO
DO THAT THAT THIS THAT'S THEIR
CAREER THEY WANT TO KEEP DOING
ITS REALLY REWARDING WORK I MEAN.
HELPING SOMEBODY GET A JOB AND
KEEP THAT JOB IS ONE OF THE MOST
FUN THINGS YOU CAN DO -- SO
ANYWAYS THAT'S A THAT'S OUR
EMPLOYMENT FIRST POLICY AND
FIRST INITIATIVE AND I GIVE YOU
GUYS A COPY OF THAT ARE -- PAID
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM WAS ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THE STATE FUNDED
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND
IT'S BEEN A WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVEN'T HAD EXPERIENCE WORKING
TO REALLY GET THAT PAID WORK
EXPERIENCE.
BUILD THEIR RESUME AND FILL
REALLY RECOGNIZED FOR THE WORK
THAT THEY'RE DOING AND WE HAVE
SEEN IT TURN INTO JOBS FOR
PEOPLE SO WE THANK YOU FOR THAT
AS WELL.
AND I'M REALLY EXCITED THAT WE
HAVE SEVERAL PEOPLE HERE TODAY
TO TALK WITH YOU GUYS ABOUT
THEIR EXPERIENCES.
WORKING AND AND THAT LOOKS LIKE
SO I'M GOING TO TURN IT OVER --
TO DOES HE HAVE A WEEK.
HELLO IT'S AFTER RECONCILING.
NOT ON THE RECORD YOU HAVE.
THE MOVEMENT OF THE DIVERSITY OF
REACH A COMPONENT OF THIS PANEL
[INAUDIBLE]
BACK.
OUR DE CITY ON THE TRIP GRAHAM
IS ONE OF THE EXCITING THINGS.
THANK THINGS HAPPEN.
HI AT A REGIONAL CENTER AND I I
GUESS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE LACK
OF ENTHUSIASM ON THE PART OF OUR
STAFF -- THAT -- REALLY ARE
ENERGIZED BY THESE PROGRAMS AND
WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THEM -- I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT OUR ARE OUT REACHED
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES -- I'M
SPEAKING ABOUT IT BECAUSE OF OUR
DIVERSITY OUT REACH SPECIALIST --
MY ROAD SHOW OF SHOWS GEN HER.
DEPENDS ON GRADUATION HE'S
RECEIVING HIS MASTER'S DEGREE
TODAY AND FOR SOME REASON SHE
THOUGHT THAT WAS AN IMPORTANT
THING TO DO.
SO ON THE THE PURCHASE OF
SERVICE DATA THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE TO US A SUGGESTS THAT
THERE THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCES.
IN THE AMOUNT OF SERVICES THAT
ARE PURCHASED.
FOR ON OUR HEADS HISPANIC PEOPLE
WHO IDENTIFY AS HISPANIC AND
PEOPLE WHO IDENTIFY AS NATIVE.
CAN IN OUR COMMUNITIES VERSUS
WHITE [INAUDIBLE]
WHITE.
AMONG THE HISPANIC COMMUNITY.
ON IT'S IT'S TRIPLE -- FOR
WHITES IT IS FOR HISPANICS IN
THEIR SIGNIFICANT DISPARITIES I
IN THE NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY --
SO WE REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE A B. X. FUNDING THAT
ENABLED US TO TO BE ABLE TO
START A AN INITIATIVE THAT WE'RE
ON WE'RE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
WERE REALLY ENERGY.
ENERGIZED ABOUT.
SO OUR FIRST QUESTION AND
LOOKING AT THESE DIFFERENCES AND
SERVICES BEING PURCHASED BY
PEOPLE PEOPLE ACROSS ETHNIC
GROUPS.
IS WHY IS THIS HAPPENING.
ON HOW DO WE EXPLAIN IT.
SO -- WE'VE HELD PUBLIC MEETINGS.
WE'VE HELD FOCUS GROUPS ON WE'VE
GONE AND SPOKEN TO TRIBAL
LEADERS.
ON TO TRY -- TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND.
HOW IT IS WELL TO IT HI EDUCATE
THEM ABOUT WHO WE ARE WHAT WE DO?
BUT TO BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT
SERVICES THEY THINK THEY NEED.
ARMY AND HOW THEY'D LIKE THEM
PROVIDED -- MORE LEARNING -- AND
BASED ON WHAT WE'RE LEARNING
THESE ARE SOME OF THE ACTIONS
THAT WERE TAKEN.
ON THAT HAVE BEEN SUPPORTED BY
A. B. X. FUNDING ONE IS THAT WE
WE HAVE SOME REMOTE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN UNDERSERVED BOTH
BECAUSE OF GEOGRAPHY.
ON AND ALSO FOR CULTURAL REASONS.
SO WE HAVE CONTRACTED WITH FOLKS
THAT WE CALL PARENT MENTORS.
ANA I'M SURE YOU'VE HEARD OF THE
PROM A TORAH APPROACH WHICH IS
SIMILAR TO THAT -- THESE ARE.
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY.
ON THEY COME FROM THE SAME
CULTURAL BACKGROUND.
ON THEY MAY SPEAK THE SAME
LANGUAGE.
ON ME AND THEY ACT AS
AMBASSADORS FOR OUR SYSTEM.
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE -- TO TALK
TO PEOPLE ABOUT REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES TO TELL THEM HOW TO
APPLY FOR THEM -- AND TO
ENCOURAGE THEM -- IN TIMES WHEN
SOME.
AT THE GROUPS ARE.
LESS UNCOMFORTABLE WITH ON
GOVERNMENT -- WE'VE CONDUCTED
PARENT EDUCATION AND SUPPORT
GROUPS FOR SPANISH SPEAKING
FAMILIES AND TRIBE MEMBERS.
NOW WE PROVIDE CHILDCARE FOOD IN
TRANSPORTATION IS NEEDED.
AND WE COULDN'T DO THESE THINGS
WITHOUT THE FUNDING ON THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED US WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR IT.
THE OTHER THING WE'VE DONE IS
WE'VE OUT STATIONED OUR STAFF --
IN THESE COMMUNITIES SO THAT
THERE ARE THERE ARE AND HEALTH
CARE CLINIC ON A PREDICTABLE
SCHEDULE.
SO THAT FAMILIES DON'T HAVE TO
TRAVEL TO US.
ON IN SO THEY CAN MEET IS IN
PLACES WHERE THEY'RE COMFORTABLE
BECAUSE A LOT OF FOLKS ARE NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH US COMING INTO
THEIR HOMES.
WE'RE TRYING TO IMPROVE OUR
COMMUNICATION WAS COMMUNITIES BY
USING SPANISH LANGUAGE RADIO.
AND SPANISH LANGUAGE NEWSPAPERS --
WE'VE CHANGED OUR ON WEBSITES SO
THAT IT CAN BE TRANSLATED INTO A
BUNCH OF LANGUAGES.
ON AN ALL OVER IMPORTANT
COMMUNICATIONS ARE TRANSLATED
INTO SPANISH BECAUSE THAT'S THE
DOMINANT LANGUAGE ARE AREAS YOU
KNOW -- WERE PRESENT AT AT A
CULTURAL AND COMMUNITY EVENTS
LIKE WE'VE NEVER BEEN BEFORE --
IF THERE'S SOMETHING HAPPENING
WERE THERE.
ON AND THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
SHOULD.
SPONSORED FUNDS ALLOW US.
TO WORK ON BUSINESS [INAUDIBLE]
HAPPY.
TO THERE'S ONE CULTURAL VALUES
CULTURAL HISTORY AND TRADITIONS
AND CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
PRACTICES -- THIS IS HUGE --
WE'VE HELD OUR HIRED ON PURCHASE
A SERVICE MEETINGS IN MARCH.
IN SPANISH SPEAKING FAMILY
MEMBERS FOR THE FIRST TIME WERE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THOSE
MEETINGS IN REAL TIME BECAUSE WE
HAD TRANSLATION EQUIPMENT.
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO PURCHASE TO
THE THE A B. X. FUNDS.
IN WHICH ALLEVIATE IS A MORE
THAN MOMENT TO SEE THESE
FAMILIES BEING ABLE TO EXPRESS
THEMSELVES TO TELL US WHAT THEY
THINK AND WHAT THEY NEED.
IN REAL TIME -- DIDN'T HAVE TO
STOP MEETING THE TRANSLATION
EQUIPMENT ALLOWED IT TO HAPPEN
FLAWLESSLY.
SO THE OUTREACH EFFORT HAS
REALLY TRIES TO US.
AND WE ANTICIPATE REDUCTIONS IN
THESE DISPARITIES OVER TIME.
SO YOU.
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
OF THAT INITIATIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WILL MOVE ON TO THE SELF
ADVOCATE COMPONENT OF OUR PANEL
AND THE FIRST.
SPEAKER DOES HE SELLS.
SHE'S WITH STAFF ALICIA DURING
HIM [INAUDIBLE]
OKAY
.
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF TO BE
REPRESENTING.
MY NAME IS DAISY.
AND I'M RESENTING -- FOR BUTLER
VALLEY.
HI MY NAME IS DAISY AND I'M HERE
TO TALK ABOUT.
THE CARLSON CENTER IT IS --
LEARNING WORKING FARM PROGRAM.
MY FAVORITE THING IS BEING A
BEEKEEPER I HAVE TO CALL
[INAUDIBLE]
HE'S. FIVE FOUR EIGHT RUDE.
KEPT CLEAN.
AND ROOMMATE [INAUDIBLE]
IS.
ON MY OWN HIGH. TO MAKE MONEY
AND SOME MY OWN HONEY.
I ALSO LIKE.
WORKING WITH THE BREEDING GOPRO.
I HAVE LEARNED TO FEED THEM GIVE
THEM MEDICINE TRIM THEIR HOOVES
AND TAKE HIM TO THE VET.
I WATCHED HIM. TO GIVE BIRTH
. TO
HOLD THEM SO THEY'RE SAFE AROUND
HUMANS.
AND TO MAKE MONEY WHEN THEY'RE
SOLD.
YOU DOING WONDERFUL KEEP IT UP.
PROUD OF YOU.
ALSO LIKE TO SO.
I LEARNED HOW TO SEW.
AND TO CUT THE TEMPLATE INTO THE
FABRIC WE MAKE CATNIP POST A
PRINT.
APRON IN BAGS.
AND TO PUT A MAN STOCK. TO MAKE
MONEY FOR LOCAL
.
I HAVE ALSO LEARNED TO SPEAK
KERN BEDS TO USED.
THE DRILL THE SERVER THE WORKERS
IN THE STAPLE GUN. TO GROW.
VEGETABLES TO HARVEST TO SELL.
TO MAKE MONEY [INAUDIBLE]
I ALSO.
LAKE LOVE. TO LEARN WORK TO MAKE
MONEY.
I'VE LEARNED.
A LOT BY MY CO WORKERS.
I LIKE TO TEACH OTHER PEOPLE
ABOUT BEES.
I WOULD LIKE TO GET A JOB ON THE
ARM [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD TO ERICA
THREE WITH COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT
SERVICES -- SIZE AGE CA ARE.
GOOD MORNING HOW ARE YOU.
I WANTED TO FIRST AND FOREMOST
IF YOU OFFER TO NEW JERSEY.
I THANK YOU ARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION.
I WILL ADMIT THAT I'M A BIT
NERVOUS -- COMING UP HERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT.
YOU'RE DOING FAN AS UNIT HAPPENS
WHEN I'M AROUND HIM ANYWAY.
OKAY.
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH PUBLIC
SPEAKING IS ONE OF THE HARDEST
THINGS IS TO DO SO -- YES WE GET
WE GET NERVOUS NOW ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND ATTENTION -- THAT ACTUALLY --
COINCIDES WITH A MY MAIN TOPIC
TODAY OF COURAGE THAT RELATES TO
OF MY SPEECH TODAY.
AND THAT -- I DO HAVE CEREBRAL
PALSY AND I WAS BORN WITH IT --
I ACTUALLY DEVELOPED TENDONITIS
IN MY LEFT ARM BECAUSE OF MY
DISABILITY THAT NOW HAD FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS.
AND I WAS OUT OF WORK.
ALL OF YOU -- TO GETTING MY JOB
AT TARGET WHICH I AM NOW
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED AND LOVING
EVERY MINUTE OF IT.
THEY'RE A GREAT COMPANY TO WORK
FOR I COULDN'T BE HAPPIER.
I LOVE WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITY SO IT WAS A GREAT FIT
FOR ME.
AND I LOVE BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE
A POSITIVE EXPERIENCE FOR THE
COMMUNITY AND MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYONE IS TAKING CARE OF MY
POINT IS IS THAT -- REDWOOD
COAST REGIONAL CENTER HAS GIVEN
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
INDEPENDENT TO HAVE THE ABILITY.
TO KNOW THAT I AM CONFIDENT
ENOUGH.
IN MY SKILL SET TO BE ABLE TO
GET GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT IN THE
BACK IN THE WORK FORCE -- IT'S
BECAUSE OF CCAR COMPRA
COMPREHENSIVE CAREER SERVICES.
THAT -- HAS ALLOWED ME TO HAVE
THE SUPPORT NEEDED. TO GET
EMPLOYED.
AND WITHOUT MARCIA HINES AND
OTHERS FELLOW MEMBERS THAT HAVE
HELPED ME OUT.
I GREATLY APPRECIATED -- AND
THAT.
BEING GAINFULLY EMPLOYED FOR ME
PERSONALLY AS WELL AS OTHER
PEOPLE HAS.
PERSONALLY HELPED ME WITH
DEPRESSION -- IT GETS DEPRESSING
TO CITY YOUR HOUSE EVERY DAY
DOING BASICALLY NOTHING.
I KNOW THAT A LOT OF VETERANS
AND OTHER PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND PEOPLE WITHOUT
DISABILITIES RELATE TO THAT.
AND THAT IT'S NICE TO FEEL
USEFUL AND IT'S NICE TO FEEL
WANTED.
SO WHEN I EVENTUALLY.
MANAGED MY CAME THROUGH PHYSICAL
THERAPY.
I WAS CONFIDENT ENOUGH TO SEEK
THE SERVICES OF RC RC. TO GET
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED.
AND WHEN THEY REFERRED ME TO CCS
I WAS CONFIDENT THAT IT WOULDN'T
TAKE LONG TO GET EMPLOYED.
AND DIED IN A HERE I AM NOW
EMPLOYED AND THAT'S WONDERFUL.
AND I JUST WANTED TO BASICALLY
SAY THAT -- HAVING THAT
INDEPENDENCE AND BEING ABLE.
TO KNOW THAT PEOPLE ARE
SUPPORTING ME.
AND NOT AS A PERSON WITH A
DISABILITY THAT I CAN BETTER MY
LIFE.
MENTALLY PHYSICALLY FINANCIALLY.
REALLY HAS A GREAT IMPACT ON MY
LIFE AS WELL AS OTHER PEOPLE'S
LIVES THAT ARE WILLING TO HELP
ME AND WATCH ME SUCCEED.
AND I REALLY JUST COULDN'T BE
HAPPIER THAT WE LIVE IN A
COMMUNITY AS SMALL AS THIS ONE
THAT HAS SO MANY SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
INCLUDING DOLERITE.
AND BUS PASSES THAT PEOPLE NEED
IT -- SERVICES LIKE RC RC IN CCS --
THAT IS JUST READILY AVAILABLE
THAT YOU KNOW WE CAN FILL
CONFIDENCE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
THEM AND KNOW THAT WE CAN BE
TAKEN CARE OF AND I JUST REALLY --
YOU KNOW JUST REALLY CAN'T THINK
THE COMMUNITY ENOUGH AND YOU
KNOW WHAT WE HAVE FOR THE SMALL.
COMMUNITY THAT WE HAVE THAT
THESE SERVICES ARE AVAILABLE.
AND THAT -- I'M JUST TERM.
JUST HAPPY THAT I CAN BE
INDEPENDENT I KNOW I HAVE
CEREBRAL PALSY I HAVE A MINOR
CASE OF IT AND I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
INDEPENDENT [INAUDIBLE]
BUT YOU KNOW I'M NOW FINANCIALLY
DOING BETTER WHICH MAKES ME
HAPPIER I'M NOW DOING PHYSICALLY
BETTER AS FAR AS PAIN MANAGEMENT.
I AM NOW DOING MENTALLY BETTER
AS FAR AS KNOWING THAT I'M
TAKING CARE OF TO THE BEST
ABILITY OF THE COMMUNITY AND THE
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED --
AND I JUST A I'M REALLY HAPPY
THAT WE HAVE THE SERVICES
BASICALLY.
AND IT'S WORKED OUT FOR ME AND I
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT IT WORKS FOR
OTHER PEOPLE DISABILITIES OR NOT
VETERANS THAT THEY CAN FEEL
CONFIDENT AND KNOWING THAT.
HELP IS AVAILABLE AND I REALLY
HOPE THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE.
REALIZE OUR FULL POTENTIAL AND
THAT THEY CAN.
ASK FOR HELP IN THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO BE AFRAID.
BECAUSE THEY ARE DISABLED AT
THAT THEY'RE IN PAIN.
THAT YOU KNOW EVENTUALLY.
THINGS CAN GET BETTER.
AND IT DOES TAKE A LOT OF HARD
WORK.
AND I'VE DEFINITELY BEEN THROUGH
THE GAUNTLET SO -- HERE I AM
TODAY STANDING BEFORE YOU.
AS A HAPPY MAN WHO'S GAINFULLY
EMPLOYED.
AND I'M VERY PROUD THAT I AM
ABLE TO HAVE THE SERVICES
AVAILABLE FOR ME -- I WANTED TO
CONCLUDE I KNOW THIS IS KINDA
SHORT BUT I WANTED TO CONCLUDE --
AND THE SPIRIT OF THE CURRENT
LINE.
FROM THE WIZARD OF OZ.
THAT HE FOUND HIS COURAGE.
I CERTAINLY HOPE THAT EVERYONE
ELSE CAN FIND THEIR COURAGE AS
WELL.
AND THAT -- YOU KNOW IT'S HARD
WORK BUT IT'S OUT THERE.
AND I AM JUST SO GRATEFUL
[INAUDIBLE]
AND A YOU OFFER YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION.
I KNOW THERE WAS A BIT SHORT.
OF THOSE ENOUGH.
OKAY.
HOW BY GOVERNESSES OUT CLEARLY?
AND THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN FOR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION.
WE NEED TO MOVE ON TO A BILL
LACY AND IT'S A SUPPORTED BY
SOLICITORS OF OUR CONSULAR I'M
SORRY DON'T HAVE DANS LES NEED
BUT COME UP IN DANNY CAN SHARE
YOUR LAST NAME IF YOU'RE HERE.
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF.
A MORE CONFIDENT OF BILLS --
FACILITATOR FOR THE ANSWERS ON
THE REGIONAL CENTER BOARD OF
DIRECTORS.
I'M THE ONLY THING AND I'VE GOT
SOMETHING TO READ -- MY NAME
MERRY ACE -- I'VE BEEN MARRIED
FOR THIRTY SEVEN YEARS AND I'M A
BOARD MEMBER.
AND I'M GOING OFF INTO ALL RIGHT
BUT I WANT TO GO BACK ON AND NOT
A YEAR AFTER YEARS UP.
BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
AND I'M A GRADUATE OF COMMITTEE.
I'M ON THE COMMITTEE FOR IT AND
I'VE BEEN IN GRASSROOTS AND I'M
AN ARTIST.
AT DIRECTORY AND TUESDAY ARE UP
AND WE HAVE -- EATEN UP AND ALSO
WE HAVE -- AT THE ALLEY WAY
ABOUT I ALLEYWAY ALL RIGHT -- SO
AND SO IT WOULD BE AS DOWNEY I
SELL MY ART.
AND I EVEN SO MY BREAST AND I'M
WEARING RIGHT NOW -- I MAY COME
IN ICE I HAVE MORE AND AYE AYE
STONE IF YOU GO.
TO ANY -- IF YOU'RE GOING TO DO
IS TO BE ALL ABOUT YOU MIGHT SEE
SOME THINGS THAT I SELL SO -- SO
THAT'S WHAT WAS HAPPENING I BEEN
THERE GRASSROOTS SO MANY YEARS.
AND I KNEW JACK BACK THOUGH --
FOR MANY YEARS AND ALSO -- I
HAVE CARE GIVERS AT HOME.
WITH MY HUSBAND BUT THEY DO NOT
HAVE -- HOLIDAY HEY AND THEN DO
YOU NEED HOLLOW THEY PAY OR FOR
THEM COME IN ON WHY MY SUPPORT
WORKER FROM A USED CAR HOW TO
COME IN AND COVER.
THAT DAY AND THEN I HAVE A GAP
FOR TO COUPLE HOURS SOMETIME SHE
NEEDS A BREAK.
BUT WE DO NEED A HOLIDAY PAY FOR
HUMBLE CARE GIVER AND PACIFIC
CARE GIVERS.
ARE VERY IMPORTANT FOR THEM
BECAUSE A START DO GIVE OUT --
GIVE HOW ARE THEY PAY SO THAT
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BECAUSE MY
HUSBAND IS DISABLED IN THE
WHEELCHAIR.
ARE YOU DONE THE WATER HELP
BECAUSE IT OPERATIC.
AND ALSO HE DOES NOT REMEMBER
VERY WELL AND HE NEEDS HELP WHAT
WITH ALL THESE SPECIAL NEEDS TO
HE NEEDS.
ON THE HOUSE WITHOUT HIM
FOLLOWING I WOULD LIKE YOU BY
STATE AND BECAUSE I'M HARD OF
HEARING.
AND WE HAVE SYSTEM IN MY HOUSE
AND WE'RE TRYING TO SET UP
ANOTHER SYSTEM.
SO WITH A BILL OUT HERE.
THE LETTER THAT MR WHERE YOU
WOULD OF YOU WOULD RECEIVE WHEN
WE MET WITH YOU REFER --
GRASSROOTS DAY.
THE BILL OF HAVE.
THE BILL ALSO HAS SOME WITH OUR
WORK OUT HERE FOR PEOPLE.
TO LOOK AT FOR SOMETIME IN THE
READ ABOUT TRAJECTORY CAM JUST A
MINUTE.
HE WON THE ELECTRONS YOU CAN AND
GO FOR IT OVER WHEN YOU CAN.
UNKNOWN THEY GET LOST.
THE THIRTY YEAR.
OKAY.
ARMAMENT REAL LETTER
[INAUDIBLE]
I'M.
AT THE IT.
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME.
THAT.
IS THIS CENTRAL INTENTIA SUPPORT
SERVICES ARE.
FIND IN TO HELP ME MAY BE MY
BASIC.
NEEDS THAT ARE NEEDED TO HELP ME
LIVE INDEPENDENTLY.
AND RECEIVE SUPPORT. FOURTEEN
LIVING SERVICES.
ON APPOINTMENTS.
WHERE I'M LOST RIGHT HERE
THROUGH?
THROUGH READY LEVINE SUPPORT.
SERVICES AND LIVE IN EUREKA.
MY SUPPORT STAFF HELPS ME
SCHEDULE APPOINTMENTS AND TO
THEM.
HELP ME WITH A HOUSTON'S MEDICAL
[INAUDIBLE]
THERE.
THEY TAKE.
ME SHOPPING.
WITH THAT.
HOPING TO GET GROCERIES TO GET
GROCERY.
GET.
THIRTY OR OTHER.
WITH THAT.
IN THE EIGHTY THINGS.
I NEED THEY ALSO HELP.
EXERCISE BY GOING.
OUT ON LONG WALKS WITH ME I ALSO
HAVE MY STAFF HELP.
WITH COOKING [INAUDIBLE]
EACH [INAUDIBLE]
TEACHERS.
YEAH TO COOK.
SKILLS N..
HELP ME AN E. HOW FEAR.
THEY ALSO HELP.
ME BUY A WRITING MY GROCERY LIST
[INAUDIBLE]
AN WHEN [INAUDIBLE]
SINGIN [INAUDIBLE]
WHAT?
ONCE HE GETS TO GO IT.
OKAY OKAY IT INSTINCTIVELY.
IN SEE WHAT THINGS I NEED FOR
CERTAIN MEALS.
MY STAFF ALSO ASSIST ME AND
BUDGETING MY MONEY TO HELP ME TO
FIND A P. SERVICE WHICH FITS MY
DESIRES AND NEEDS.
I LIKE TAKING WEEKEND TRIPS SO
THIS HELPS A LOT WITH THAT.
IS IMPORTANT THAT THE SERVICE IS
FUNDED TO MEET THE GO TO IN OUR
PROGRAM CALLED PROJECT WE WHICH
IS ALSO IN EUREKA.
I ENJOY MAKING ART THERE I HAVE
SOLD ARTWORK AND A VOLUNTEER
EVERY SATURDAY AFTER.
THE MORRIS GRAVES MUSEUM OF ART.
THERE IS ALSO SOME BROCHURES
OUTSIDE ABOUT MORRIS GRAVES
MUSEUM AND TONIGHT IS -- THE
KICK OFF TO WILL -- REDWOOD
COAST JAZZ FESTIVAL IN RUBY
MUSIC [INAUDIBLE]
POURING WINE.
A HOME SO THIS PROGRAM HE GAVE
THAT MORRIS GRAVES MUSEUM OF ART
THE VOLUNTEERS EVERY EVERY
SATURDAY THIS IS FUN.
AND HELP ME BUILD MORE SKILLS
AGREE PEOPLE THERE AND SHOW THEM
WHERE. TO GO WHEN THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR THINGS.
THIS PROGRAM NEEDED FUNDING
INCREASED AS WELL TO HELP ME OUT
AND HELP ME AND OTHER ORDERS OUT.
THINGS WERE NOT GOOD FOR ME WHEN
I DO NOT HAVE TO POOR SERVICES I
NEEDED.
I DO NOT KILL THE HELP I NEEDED
AND AND LIVING INDEPENDENTLY WAS
HARD.
IT WAS AND HEALTHIER I DO NOT
GET ENOUGH EXERCISE OR EAT
HEALTHY I SMOKED.
IT WAS HARD FOR ME TO SAVE MONEY.
PROBLEMS TAKING MY MEDICATION
AND I DID NOT LIVE IN PLACES
THAT WERE GOOD FOR ME.
MY LIFE IS SO MUCH BETTER NOW
THAN I AM SUPPORT SERVICES
AVAILABLE TO ME.
I COULD NOW TAKE MY MEDICATIONS
REGULARLY I HAVE MONEY TO GO ON
TRIPS I AM ABLE TO GO TO MY
APPOINTMENT TO REGULARLY.
I EAT HEALTHIER.
YOU GET MORE EXERCISE I SO ART
WORK AND INTERACT WITH FRIENDS
WHILE DOING IT.
I HAVE A LOT LESS ANXIETY AND
KNOWING THE SUPPORT. FOR THE
HOUSE SUPPORT HELPS WITH.
IS IMPORTANT FOR MY HEALTH.
THESE ARE JUST A FEW REASONS WHY
FUNDING SERVICES IS SO IMPORTANT.
ADD THIS THIS IS BEEN ADDED
SINCE SINCE WE WITH YOU.
I HAVE SERVED ON THE REGIONAL
CENTER BOARD OF DIRECTORS SINCE
JULY OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
I'M A MEMBER OF THE EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE.
AND I'M A CLIENT REPRESENTATIVE.
I ATTENDED GRASSROOTS DAY IN
APRIL ALONG WITH MARY AND HER
STAFF IN A MIRROR OCHO AND THE
OTHER STAFF.
AND WE TALKED.
TO LEGISLATORS ABOUT.
ISSUES AFFECTING ME AN OLDER
CLIENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
WE ALSO MET WITH SB BET WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD IN HIS
STAFF AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC
MIKE MCGUIRE.
AND EIGHTY ARE CURRY AND HER
STAFF.
YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT SOME OF THESE
ISSUES TODAY AMONG THE THINGS WE
TALKED ABOUT WERE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING EMPLOYMENT IN A RATE
INCREASE OF 8%.
WHICH WILL BE IMPORTANT ACROSS
THE BOARD SO THAT.
OUR SERVICE PROVIDERS CAN THE
NEEDS OF THE CLIENTS.
I ANCHORED CLIENTS INTERESTED IN
SERVING ON THE REGIONAL SERVER
BOARD. TO CONTACT THE BOARD
CONTACT REGIONAL CENTER AND TO
APPLY.
IT IS IMPORTANT.
IN A GOOD WAY FOR CLIENTS TO
ASSERT THEIR RIGHTS IN MAINTAIN
SERVICES.
THAT ARE ESSENTIAL TO THEM.
TRY THAT WITH HIM AND NOW BILL
IS GONNA TALK FIRST A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT.
ABOUT TO JACK [INAUDIBLE]
HI AGAIN.
GREAT GREAT CAN YOU HEAR ME
[INAUDIBLE]
YES.
IF YOU MAKE IT TO THE TO THE
CHICKEN.
JUDGE IN THE DEATH.
OF YOUR DIRECTORY IS
[INAUDIBLE]
A CAREER CAREER DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES THAT SUPPORT.
HELLO THIS VISUAL ARTIST
[INAUDIBLE]
PERFORMANCE.
RIGHT IT'S AN ART SINCE ARTISANS.
THE BAR WITH DISABILITIES WITH
DISABILITIES TO BECOME
[INAUDIBLE]
ECONOMICALLY ECONOMICALLY SELF.
SUFFICIENT SUFFICIENT ROOM.
THEIR ART TO DIRECTORY SUPPORT
EACH ARTIST USED IN ALL
[INAUDIBLE]
STATE.
WAS IT CAREERS CAREERS SHOP.
DIRECTORY SUPPORTS ARTIST IN
COMMUNITY [INAUDIBLE]
SPACES FLAG.
MISSION MADNESS TO STREET ART
LAMB.
COLLEGE OF THE REDWOODS AND
SCRATCH. TO DIRECTORY ALSO
SUPPORTS ARTISTS IN THEIR HOMES.
OR AS MEDICAL OFFICES FOR
ARTISTS WHO.
ARE [INAUDIBLE]
MONA CLEAN [INAUDIBLE]
FRAGILE SH. THREE PROVIDE
EMPLOYMENT.
MINUTES SERVICES FOR ARTISTS
[INAUDIBLE]
WITH THEIR WITH SCRIPT WRITING
VOLUNTEERED WHICH LOCAL ARE YOU.
MUSICIANS.
ORGANIZATIONS ORGANIZATIONS.
PORTFOLIO DEVELOPER.
FOR I CAN'T DO THAT. FOR YOU
DEVELOPMENT.
AT OUR SHOWS.
LUCIEN PREPARATIONS AN STEP. TO
SELF EMPLOYMENT.
DOES YOUR STORY NUMBER THREE MY
STORY NOW.
I'M THINKING THAT THAT.
I NEED HELP -- THIS IS MY DIRECT
THREE HELPED ME VOLUNTEER AT THE
MOORS GRADE MUSEUM ON SATURDAYS.
I REALLY ENJOYED HEARING AT THE
MUSEUM IT IS FUN.
I'VE BEEN VOLUNTEERING THERE FOR
TWO YEARS.
WITH THE SUPPORT OF TWO
DIRECTORY TONIGHT I WILL BE.
POINT ONE IN.
MARGE GRAY I ALSO. FOR THE JAZZ
FOR THE WORLD I ALSO.
BUT MAKING ART WHICH WITH
DIRECTORY.
I AM WORKING ON A PORTFOLIO.
DRAIN FOR A ALSO RESTRICT SO
SHOWN CHAU [INAUDIBLE]
LAST.
LAST YEAR LAST YEAR I WORKED ON
A COLLABORATION.
HI MISSION WITH A LOCAL ART A OR
LOWER WHO -- SIGNAL.
AND THEN AND THEN COULD SEE YOU
HERE YEAH FOR A SHOW CALL HOME
[INAUDIBLE]
PETER [INAUDIBLE]
I'M.
PERCENT EXCITED EXCITED FOR TO
DIRECTORY. TO SUPPORT ME WITH
USING THE OLD TOWN.
IN.
LAB SO THAT.
I'VE LEARNED. TO DO.
THANK YOU AND TO SUPPORT ME N.
B. IN.
BECOMING A VOLUNTEER FOR THE
FERNDALE REPERTORY THEATRE
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
THE BILL HAS NOT WORK AND I HAVE
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I'VE BEEN
DOING -- OF MAKING FOLKS FOR MY
FAMILY AND ALSO I AM I DO PART.
I'M WORKING ON MAKING BOOKS I'M
GOING ON HOW TO MAKE DIFFERENT
BOOK.
AND I DID THE BOOK WORKSHOP
COUPLE TIMES.
AND USUALLY I HAVE TO HAVE HELP
BECAUSE I I TEND TO GET
SCATTERBRAINED SO THAT'S WHY --
DIRECTLY WITH THE GOOD.
HE WAS BECAUSE THEY KEEP YOU ON
TRACK AND THEY HELP YOU COULD
TAKE THAT CALL FEEL TATERS.
AND THAT'S OUR OUR WORK BASED ON
STUDIO SO NOW IT SAYS WE HAVE
EATEN UP.
I GET A BOOK OVER TO TO MAKE MY
BOOKS AND THEY THEY DON'T KNOW
TRACE MY ARE OUT TO AYE.
DRAWN ON THE REGULAR PAPER THEN
I PUT IN MY FINAL PAPER I COULD
PUT IT ON BIG WHITE BOX.
GOING.
TO OF THE INK PEOPLE SO THIS WAY
I COULD JUST GO AROUND THE
CORNER AND GO TO THE MY IN LAB
WHEN THEY OPEN AND I COULD GO
WORK ON MY DRAWING AND THINGS.
SO -- JOHN BEEN TRYING TO WORK
ON THE BOOK AND ALSO I'M GONNA
BE DOING SHOT SHOW.
BUT I'M LEARNING HOW TO DO NEW
MEDIUM AND IT'S VERY HARD TO
LEARN THIS NEW MEDIUM ON WATER
COOLER IT'S NOT EASY.
AND I JUST COME IS GOOD WITH IT
SO SO THEY HAVE TO HELP GUIDE ME.
UNTIL I GET COMFORTABLE WITH
THAT SO THEY GOT ME ON THE
COMPUTER AND GO DIE WITH
SOMEBODY WHO.
WHO'S DOING THE OUR YOU TUBE AND
FOLLOW ALONG SO I GIVEN ANY KIND
OF OUR NATURE COULD I DO OUT IN
NATURE.
OF WRITING AND NOT A NATURE ON
DRAWING SO THAT'S MY PASSION UP
THAT.
AND ALSO I DO ARE OUT OF A
DIFFERENT MEDIUM AND ALSO I DO
ON OUR OWN.
A DRAFT UP TO RIGHT RIGHT THE
MOST SAKE AND RIBBON BRAIDING
THAT I'M WEARING AND I DO A LOT
OF THAT AND DRINK IT THINK.
I HAVE THOSE WITH SALES SO I'VE
BEEN DOING.
ABOUT IT -- MODERN ART SHOWS I
HAVE TOLD MY FIRST ONE WHEN I
FIRST YEAR I I GOT A A FIRST
TIME AND I SAW MY ART THAT FIRST
YEAR.
AND THEN SOME OF MY ART GOT SOLD
AND IT'S VERY VERY HARD TO GET.
PEOPLE BUY ART -- BECAUSE IS NOT --
EASY.
TO I THEM CAN WE WE TEND TO PUT
TOO HIGH A PRICE ON ON AND
BECAUSE OF OUR FRAMED.
ARE WE HAVE TO COULD ARE FRAME
TWICE IN THE TO ORDER TO SELL IT
AND LET IT DROP.
TAKE IT OUT OF IT WILL GO TO US.
AND THAT WHATEVER THE THE YEAH.
FIND THE PLACE TO DO IT RIGHT
NOW I'M DOING ANOTHER STAFF.
ON ON SHARK.
AND SO WHEN SHE SAYS SHE'S DOING
ITS JOB I'LL GO DO IT WITH YOU
AT THE COCA RAIDER SO BOTH OF US
CARRY SHARKS SO I GOT PART OF IT
DONE BUT I'M STILL WORKING ON
HOW TO DEAL WITH -- WITH
WATERCOLORS JUNE WE HARD SO
THAT'S WHAT WORK WAS HAPPENING
THERE AND SO I WILL DO A TWO
DAYS A WEEK SO DOES NOT DISARM
DAN AND AND VISIT US AND YOU SEE
WHAT WE DO.
THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR AS WE'VE HEARD FROM THE FORM
THE TWO SPEAKERS -- ABOUT
TRAJECTORY WE'RE GOING TO CALL
TO THIS PANEL SOPHIA HOLDER
[INAUDIBLE]
HERE [INAUDIBLE]
GOOD MORNING.
I'M A SENIOR.
SORRY.
MY FULL POINTS ARE KIND OF MESSY
SO.
TRY MY BEST -- SO I GET TO GO TO
TRAJECTORY AND I'VE BEEN GOING
FOR THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS AND
I GET -- TO WORK ON MY ART THERE
AND I WENT TO SEE OUR FOR A
COUPLE SEMESTERS AFTER I GOT OUT
OF HIGH SCHOOL AND I TOOK A
CERAMICS CLASS.
I WANTED TO DO CERAMICS MORE BUT
I DIDN'T HAVE THE MEANS TO DO IT
AT HOME I DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO
A KILN OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
BUT BECAUSE THE TRAJECTORY I GET
ACCESS TO A KILL AND I COULD TO
MAKE MY BIG WEIRD SCULPTURES.
IN.
THE HOME I GET TO LEARN NEW
THINGS ABOUT CERAMICS AND
SCULPTING AND I'VE LEARNED HOW
TO DO SLIP CASTING AND AND MOLD
MAKING AND IT'S BEEN A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME AND NOW ALSO
THROUGH THE PAID INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM I GET TO WORK THERE.
AS A ON THE STUDIO TECHNICIAN
INSIDE I GET TO HAVE A JOB IN
THE ARTS WHICH IS SOMETHING I'VE
ALWAYS REALLY WANTED.
AND IT'S A GOOD JOB FOR ME
BECAUSE IT'S NOT STRESSFUL AND I
AM STILL MOTIVATED TO DO ART
BECAUSE I'M NOT TOO TIRED FROM
WORKING [INAUDIBLE]
AND THREE IN [INAUDIBLE]
FORGETTING
.
IT'S CAN A MESSY.
THERE.
OKAY.
I DO OWN I HAVE A BETTER SENSE
OF JOB SECURITY AND I'M AFRAID
TO LOSE MY JOB BY.
I HAVE HAD A COUPLE JOBS IN THE
PAST NINE TO GET FIRED AT ONE
POINT SO.
NOW I GET TO GO TO MY I'M IN I
DO MY JOB AND I DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT.
MAYBE NOT BEING ABLE TO COME IN
THE NEXT DAY AND I LIVE IN
MCKINLEY BILL AND I CAN'T DRIVE
IN SO THE REGIONALS CENTER GIVE
ME BUS PASSES.
SO I CAN TAKE THE BUS TO WORK.
SOME OF MY MOM DOESN'T HAVE TO
DRIVE ME.
IN THE OWN.
I AM THE I GET TO FEEL
PRODUCTIVE AT MY JOB AND I HELP
MAKE A SHELF IN IN THE TABLE AND
I AM I GUESS AND DO THINGS MY
HANDS.
I LIKE THAT AND MAKES ME FEEL
ACCOMPLISHED AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE MY JOB AND I GET TO
DO WHAT I'VE ALWAYS WANTED AND
HAVING A JOB IN THE ARTS AND I
WILL GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY.
NOT ALL THAT I WROTE SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
SO WE CAN MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
PANEL -- WITH THE HUMBOLDT
COUNTY OFFICE CATION.
BUDGET.
MACY'S.
IF I BUTCHERED YOUR NAME I
APOLOGIZE RIGHT THANK YOU AND I
WROTE A COLLEAGUE SHALL BE
PETERSON.
AND I KNOW -- TODAY WHEN I WAS
ASKED TO COME I DIDN'T REALLY
PUT ANYTHING TOGETHER BECAUSE
IT'S TIME TO MOVE THE
CONVERSATION.
THAN ANYTHING AND SO MY JOB AT
THE COUNTY OFFICES I'M A
PRINCIPAL AND I'M A PROGRAMS
BIRTH. TO FIVE FOR CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES AND IT'S BASICALLY
EARLY INTERVENTION AND THERE'S
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PROGRAMS
WITHIN THAT CERTIFIED.
I'M THE ONE I'M GONNA TALK A BIT
ABOUT MORE TO DATE IS A
COLLABORATIVE WITH REGIONAL
CENTER AND WE DO RUN -- TWO
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS -- AND ONE IS
VENDOR RICE REGIONAL CENTER AND
THAT'S AN EIGHTEEN MONTH A THREE
YEAR OLD CLASSROOM.
AND WE HAVE THREE CLASSROOMS
HERE AND THIS AND THAT SERVE
CHILDREN.
SO I KNOW EARLIER -- ONE OF THE
OTHER SPEAKERS TALKED ABOUT --
THE IMPORTANCE OF EARLY
INTERVENTION AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT SHELBY BECAUSE
WE ARE -- WE'RE VERY CLAPPING
TOGETHER INTO ONE FORGET
ANYTHING -- SO WHAT'S WORKING
WELL HERE IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY ONE
IS THAT COLLABORATION AND I
THINK IF YOU TAKE ANYTHING AWAY
TODAY.
IT'S THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING
AGENCIES AND ALSO PRIVATE
BUSINESS BE ABLE TO BE
INCENTIVIZE TO WORK.
AND CREATE RELATIONSHIPS AND SO --
THE ONE WITH THE I. REGIONAL
CENTER STARTED ABOUT TWELVE
YEARS AGO I'VE BEEN WITH THE
COUNTY OFFICE FOR FOURTEEN YEARS.
AND WE HAD A NEED WE HAD --
CHILDREN OUGHT TO THAT WERE.
SINCE SOME OF YOU WE AND EARLY
INTERVENTION BECAUSE WE KNOW
REALLY GOOD INTER INTER EARLY
INTERVENTION -- AT MAKES LAST
SEEN OUTCOMES RIGHT SO AND THE
EARLIER YOU GET CHILDREN THE
BETTER THE OUTCOME SO -- FROM
FOUR TO ONE HUGE DIFFERENCE IF
YOU GET CHILDREN.
SO -- THIS PARTICULAR
RELATIONSHIP WITH REGIONAL
CENTER -- WAS BECAUSE WE HAD A
GOOD WORKING DIALOGUE AND WHICH
IS NOT COMMON IN THE STATE I'M
WELL MY COLLEAGUES IN OTHER
PARTS OFTEN TALK ABOUT.
UNDER CHALLENGES WORKING WITH
REGIONAL CENTER FROM THE SCHOOL
PERSPECTIVE AND I'M SURE THE
REVERSE IS ON THE OTHER SIDE --
BUT YOU'RE WERE SMALL COMMUNITY
AND WE SEE EACH OTHER AT THE
GROCERY STORE AND WE TALK TO
EACH OTHER AND ALL THAT KIND OF
STUFF HAPPENS SO -- WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO AT TO HAVE THIS --
MEMORANDUM OF AGREEMENT.
AND SO -- DOT THAT CLASSROOM
WHICH USED TO BE ONE CHILD EARLY --
IS NOW THREE CHILDREN -- THREES
GIVE ME THREE CLASSROOMS FOR
CHILDREN EIGHT EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
TO THREE AND WE SERVE CHILDREN
WITH AUTISM BUT THEY DON'T HAVE
TO HAVE THAT DISABILITY
NECESSARILY THEY CAN HAVE SOME
ARE LIKE CHARACTERISTICS SO THEY
CAN HAVE DEFICITS IN SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL COMMUNICATION ADAPTIVE
BEHAVIOR.
AND BE SERVED BY THAT CLASSROOM --
AND THE REASON WE HAVE THREE IS --
FAMILIES LOVE THEM.
AND THEY REALLY HAVE GREAT
OUTCOMES AND SO -- THEY'RE VERY
NOW.
IN DEVELOPMENTAL SO CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES WHEN THEY WALK IN.
IT LOOKS JUST LIKE A PRESCHOOL
CLASSROOM AND IT FEELS LIKE THAT
AND THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE
SOME SUPPORT TO THE FAMILY AS
WELL AS A CHILD BECAUSE WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BIRTH TO
FIVE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT NOT
JUST SERVING THE CHILDREN.
BUT THEIR FAMILIES AS WELL.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
WORKED REALLY WELL I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
CLASSROOM ITSELF BECAUSE I DON'T
REALLY KNOW YOUR BACKGROUND.
AND EARLY INTERVENTION WHAT YOU
KNOW OR YOU DON'T KNOW -- AND SO
I THINK IF YOU COULD HAVE A
PICTURE OF WHAT THAT IT.
AND I THINK D. M. BIGGEST
BENEFIT FOR FAMILIES IS THERE
NOT HAVING TO GO THROUGH
SEPARATIST CESSNA PROCESSES.
AND THEN BECAUSE WE HAVE
FAMILIES I HAVE FAMILY THAT
DROVE FROM RED WAY THIS WAY WEEK
THREE TIMES FOR ASSESSMENTS.
THEY HAD TO DO THAT TWICE FOR
EACH AGENCY WHEN THEY TURNED
THREE THAT CREATES A BEAR FOR
ACCESSING SERVICES.
AND SO WHAT WHAT WE'RE FINDING A
CLASSROOM THAT SET UP LIKE A
TODDLER CENTER IS THAT CHILDREN
ARE ABLE TO ACCESS SERVICES --
WHERE MAYBE THEY WERE ABLE TO
GET ENOUGH ABA PROVIDERS BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT'S THAT AND SPACE
ACTORS FOR CHILDREN IN A SERIES
OF THE TALK MORE ABOUT THAT
LATER?
BUT WE KNOW THAT THEY NEED THOSE
SAYS BECAUSE FOR OUTCOMES LATER
IN LIFE.
IF WE CAN CHANGE OUR TRAJECTORY
THEY'RE GONNA NEED LESS SERVICES
AS THEY GET OLDER.
I'M IN ADDITION A THINK WHAT'S
UNIQUE IN A BARRIER RIGHT NOW
THAT WAS SPOKEN TO EARLIER.
IS THAT OUR COUNTY HAS THE
HIGHEST ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCE NUMBERS IN THE STATE.
WHAT HAPPENS IS YOU HAVE A
LITTLE TWO YEAR OLD?
MAYBE THEY'RE EXPOSED TO TRAUMA
OR THEY HAVE -- OTHER DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE GOING ON IN THE HOME
THAT CHILD CAN LOOK LIKE A CHILD
AUTISM.
AND WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO ARE
YOU GOING TO DENY THEM SERVICES
BECAUSE THEY HAVE HIGH ACES
SCORES BECAUSE WE THINK IT MIGHT
BE THAT WELL WE DON'T DO THAT IN
THIS COUNTY.
THEY'RE ABLE TO ACCESS SERVICES
REGARDLESS OF WHAT WE THINK IT
MIGHT BE AND THAT'S SOMETHING TO
THINK ABOUT IS THE STATE AS WE
LOOK AT WHAT NEEDS ARE FOR
SERVICES AND REALLY THINK ABOUT
THAT MENTAL HEALTH COMPONENT.
IN ADDITION THE COUNTY OFFICE
HAS A COLLABORATIVE EFFORT ZERO
EIGHT MENTAL HEALTH COOPERATIVE
THAT MAKE WALKLEY INVEST HEAVILY
IN HAVE BEEN A PART OF IN REALLY
TRYING TO EDUCATE.
INDIVIDUALS THAT -- TO BUT IF
THEY DON'T HAVE THOSE NEEDS HOW
DO THEY GET INTO THOSE.
AND SO HAVING FUNDING FOR OTHER
QUALITY INTERVENTION I THINK IS
CRITICAL.
OR THAT PACIFIC DIAGNOSIS REALLY
THAT'S WHAT THE TICKET IS SET TO
GET INTO PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
THE OTHER PART OF HIM AGAIN AS
THEY WERE RULES SO OUR FAMILIES
ARE TRAVELING REALLY FAR TO GET
TO THESE SERVICES.
AND THE OTHER BIG THING WHICH I
KNOW IT M. YOU KNOW PART THE
COUNTY OFFICE IS PARTICIPATING
IN A LOT OF LIKE RANTS RIGHT NOW
WE'RE PART OF THE CITY IT'S A
SUPPORT INCLUSIVE PRACTICES
GRANT AND WE'VE APPLIED FOR TWO
OTHER GRANTS. TO CREATE MORE
INCLUSIVE OPPORTUNITIES IS THE
LACK OF ACCESS TO GENERAL
EDUCATION PRESCHOOLS.
AND CHILDCARE FOR MANY OF OUR
FAMILIES IF YOU.
HAVE A CHILD WITH A DISABILITY
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A REALLY HARD
TIME FINDING CARE.
AND A GOOD CARE AND SO -- IS
SPECIFICALLY THIS COUNT WE DO
NOT HAVE ENOUGH CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS FOR THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN AND SO WHAT HAPPENS IS
ARE TALKING PROVIDERS CAN PICK
AND CHOOSE WHICH KIDS THEY WANT.
AND SO I HAVE A NUMBER OF KIDS
WHO HAVE BEEN KICKED OUT OF
PRESCHOOLS NUMBERS OF TIMES I
THINK THAT'S AT THE STATE LEVEL
THAT'S ALSO BEEN NOTED ABOUT THE
THE HIGH RATE.
THAT HIGH RATE HAPPENING -- SO
HAVING -- THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE MORE INCLUSIVE PARTNERSHIPS
WITH -- NO PRIVATE PRESCHOOLS OR
A NOTE AND STATE PRESCHOOLS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT WOULD BE
ANOTHER GREAT THING FOR THE
STATE TO LOOK AT I KNOW STATE
PRESCHOOLS AND HAVE STARTS ARE
SUPPOSED TO SERVE A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF KIDS WELL I'M WHO HAVE
SPECIAL NEEDS.
BUT WOULDN'T FRANKLY IT'S GOING
TO BE THOSE CHILDREN WHO ARE
MORE MILD NEEDS AT END OF
ACCESSING THOSE THOSE PROGRAMS
THE CHILDREN WHO ARE MORE UNIQUE
NEEDS LIKE KIDS WITH AUTISM OR
OTHER TYPES OF DISABILITIES ARE
GOING TO HAVE A HARD TIME --
THOSE AGENCIES JUST DON'T HAVE
THE SKILL SET OR THE RESOURCES
TO BE ABLE.
TO YOU KNOW MEET THOSE KIDS
WHERE THEY'RE AT AND SO -- I
KNOW THAT -- WHAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE MORE IS MORE PARTNERSHIPS
IS I'M WILLING TO PARTNER WITH
THE COUNTY OFFICE? TO RUN
CLASSROOMS -- SO WE HAVE THAT
AND FOR INCLUSION REAL INCLUSION
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO HAVE EQUITY
WE HAVE TO HAVE BE ABLE TO MEET
KIDS WHERE THEY'RE AT AND THAT
DOES MEAN THINKING DIFFERENTLY
THAT MEAN LOOKING AT YOUR
RESOURCES DIFFERENTLY.
AND THEN FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
MANDATED TO PROVIDE IT IS SOME
TYPE OF INCENTIVE TO DO IT -- SO
UP HERE I THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THE BIG CHALLENGES AS YOU GUYS
GO BACK TO THAT ARE.
THERE REALLY STRUCK.
COOL IN CHILDCARE.
WE'RE STRUGGLING TO GET KIDS
[INAUDIBLE]
I NEED.
IN PRESCHOOL THAT JUST GOES
ALONG WITH YOU I MEAN YOU GROW
UP WITH THAT EXPECTATION.
THE KIDS YOU GO TO PRESCHOOL
WITH GREW UP WITH THAT
EXPECTATION AS WELL THAT THAT
JUST WITH NORMAL LOOKS LIKE IS
RANGE OF PEOPLE.
AND THEIR FAMILIES EXPECTED AS
WELL AND SO -- UP HERE THAT'S
THAT'S BEEN VERY CHALLENGING I
KNOW THAT'S CHALLENGING ACROSS
THE STATE -- I I TRAVEL AROUND
FOR THIS POSITION AND I GET TO
SEE OTHER PROGRAMS.
LAST WEEK WE WERE AN LA LOOKING
AT THEIR INCLUSIVE PRESCHOOLS.
THEY'RE VERY RICH DISTRICTS THAT
ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT -- AND
THEIR CLOSE TOGETHER SO THEY
DON'T HAVE THE SAME CHALLENGES
THAT WE DO -- BUT SO YOU KNOW --
WHAT I WANT TO LEAVE YOU AND IN
SOME WAYS IS THAT WHAT THE
THINGS ARE GOING REALLY WELL AS
THAT COLLABORATION AND THAT
TAKES A LOT OF RELATIONSHIP
BUILDING AND I THINK THAT'S
CHALLENGING WHEN YOU HAVE?
YOU KNOW CASE MANAGERS WHO HAVE
HIGH CASELOADS THAT THEY CAN'T --
THIS IS OUR ENGAGE IN THE SAME
WAY THEY WANT -- TO AND WE HAVE
LIMITED SERVICE PROVIDERS SO YOU
OR MAYBE THE HAVE CERTAIN PEOPLE
AND THEY WANT TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY BUT YOU CAN'T
FIND OTHER PEOPLE TO WORK WITH --
BUT THEN AS WELL AS YOU KNOW
THAT.
AT THIS LOCAL LEVEL WERE REALLY
TRYING TO MAXIMIZE AND
EFFECTIVELY USE ALL OUR
RESOURCES AND I THINK THAT I
THINK THAT'S IT THE THING ABOUT
A GOVERNMENT AGENCY THAT'S
IMPORTANT IS THAT YOU CAN DO A
REALLY GOOD JOB WITH LIMITED
RESOURCES.
YOU HAVE TO COME TOGETHER AND
YOU HAVE TO UTILIZED EACH
OTHER'S RESOURCES -- SO I DON'T
KNOW I MEAN I CAN I CAN TALK A
LOT.
ABOUT WHAT WE DO AND I BUT I
WANT TO STAY ON POINT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT [INAUDIBLE]
WILTON.
IT CAME FROM THE HEART.
WE'RE GOING TO CONNECT LATER ON
TO TO TALK ABOUT.
ADVANCING WHICH WERE DISCUSSED
SO THANK YOU.
DOES HERE.
THIS IS A WARM MOMENT CAPTAIN
YEAH ZERO BREAKS IS BACK UP.
I'M ACTUALLY GONNA TURN IT OVER
TO DR SMALLEY -- SO BUT I WILL
TALK ABOUT WAR BLAME BRIEFLY
THEY ARE ONE OF OUR PARTNERS
THEY'RE BASED IN SACRAMENTO BUT
THEY'RE THAT PARENT TRAINING AND
INFORMATION CENTER.
AND SO THE NEW HEARD WHEN I WAS
TALKING BEFORE ABOUT
COLLABORATION IS SOMETHING NEAR
AND DEAR TO MY HEART SO PART OF
WHAT -- I'VE DONE IN MY PREVIOUS
ROLE OF REGIONAL CENTER IS
COLLABORATE WITH MORE MIND -- TO
SUPPORT THE FAMILIES THAT WE
SERVE IN OUR FOR COUNTIES TO
ACCESS THAT RESOURCE BECAUSE
THEY DO COVER ARE FOR COUNTIES
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE BASED IN
SACRAMENTO SO WE PARTNER WITH
THEM.
AND THEY COME UP HERE IN THE
OFFER TRAININGS TO FAMILIES I'M
AROUND SPECIAL EDUCATION LAW AND
SUPPORTING FAMILIES TO NAVIGATE
THAT AN ADVOCATE FOR THEIR CHILD
TO GET THEIR NEEDS MET IN THE
SCHOOL SETTING -- AND THAT WE
MET THEM THROUGH OUR THE CAPTAIN
THE CALIFORNIA ON SOME SPECIAL
TRAINING AND INFORMATION NETWORK
AND I'M GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO
DR SMALLEY WHOSE ARE AUTISM
CLINICAL SPECIALIST AND CAN MUCH
BETTER SPEAK TO THAT I THINK
YOUR CONDUCTOR.
THANK YOU -- I HAVE -- WELL LIKE
ALL CLINICIANS OF THE REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM AND ALL CONDITIONS
IN OUR WORLD COMMUNITY.
I WEAR MULTIPLE HATS.
THERE AREN'T ENOUGH OF US.
IN THE REGION CENTER OR IN OUR
TOWN TO GO AROUND RIGHT.
SO I AM THE AUTISM CLINICAL
SPECIALIST.
I AM ALSO THE BEHAVIOR ANALYST
FOR ALL FOR COUNTIES.
AND I AM ALSO THE PERSON WHO
REGIONAL CENTER HAS WHO WORKS
WITH A KNOWS A LITTLE SOMETHING
ABOUT SPECIAL ED LAW.
FULL INCLUSION INTEGRATION --
PARENT EDUCATION PARA RIGHTS
ETCETERA -- I'M ALSO THE PERSON
WHO TRAINS ARE LOCAL POLICE
OFFICERS ON WHAT TO DO WHEN
THEY'RE IN SOMEBODY WITH AUTISM.
I'M ALSO THE PERSON WHO TRAINS
ARE LOCAL OTHER FIRST RESPONDERS
AND FIREMAN ON WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THEY'RE THE FIRST PEOPLE ON THE
SCENE.
SO THAT TAKE AWAY POINT THERE IS
YOU IN ANY OF THE PEOPLE COME UP
AND SPOKE TO YOU.
WE ARE ONE HUMAN WITH. THREE
FIVE SEVEN ROLES -- WE ARE
WORKING TREMENDOUSLY HARD AND
DOING FABULOUS THINGS THAT
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THIS MORNING.
BUT THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS
THE NEED OUTSTRIPS SUPPLY IN
EVERY AREA -- WHETHER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ACTUAL PEOPLE TO
GET JOB TRAINING AND TO WORK
WHETHER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
AGENCIES OR WHETHER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CLINICIANS OR
SERVICE COORDINATORS.
NEED OUTSTRIPS SUPPLY OKAY.
ON THE CALIFORNIA AUTISM PART IN
TRAINING INFORMATION NETWORK
ACTUALLY.
HE HE LEFT THAT CAME OUT OF THE
ORIGINAL BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION.
AND IT WAS THE IDEA THAT WE WE
HAVE AN EXPONENTIAL GROWTH OF OF
INDIVIDUALS LABELED AUTISM STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE HIGHEST --
WATCH WORKS LET'S STOP FINDING
THINGS THAT DON'T WORK LET'S
ACTUALLY MAKE SOME SOME
DIFFERENCE AND LET'S DO IT AS
SOON AS WE CAN.
AND CAPTAIN IS A COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE SCHOOL SYSTEMS THE
SELF AS THE REGIONAL CENTER --
THE UNIVERSITY CENTERS OF
EXCELLENCE THE FEDERALLY
MANDATED PARENT TO PARENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND THAT IS A ONE
LINE IS OUR VERSION OF THAT HERE --
BUT IN THESE FOUR COUNTIES WE
DON'T HAVE A CENTER OF
EXCELLENCE.
I DON'T HAVE A UNIVERSITY CENTER
YOU SAID HERE.
AND OUR PARENTS PARENT NETWORK
IS HOUSE OUT OF SACRAMENTO DO
WONDERFUL THINGS THEY COME IN
THEY TELL HEALTHY DO TRAININGS.
THEY ARE ONE LINE IS FABULOUS.
BUT I DON'T HAVE ALL THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO ME ON A
DAY TO DAY BASIS IN THE SAME WAY
THAT OAKLAND SAN FRANCISCO OR LA
DOES.
WE DO KNOW WHAT WORKS WE DO KNOW
WHAT BEST PRACTICES ARE WE WE
THE RIGHT AWAY WE DO KNOW WHAT
MAKES A DIFFERENCE.
BEING ABLE TO IMPLEMENT IT AND
IMPLEMENTED WITH CONFIDENCE
THANK YOU STEVE AND NOT ADEQUACY --
IS A EVERY DAY PERPETUAL
STRUGGLE -- I GOT HERE.
AT TWELVE YEARS AGO AND WE HAD.
ONE AB A PROVIDER. ONE FOR ALL
FOR COUNTIES.
WE NOW HAVE.
SIX THAT'S FABULOUS WE HAVE
FORTY BOARD CERTIFIED BE AROUND
UNLESS IF YOU SPEAK TO ANY OTHER
REGIONAL CENTER.
ANY OTHER GEOGRAPHICAL AREA THE
NUMBER FORTY IS RIDICULOUS.
WE SIMPLY NOT HAVE NOT PROVIDERS
.
TO AUTISM SPECTRUM DISORDER AT
AT THE SAME [INAUDIBLE]
PROVIDE ALL.
OUR SERVER WHOSE NEEDS -- EXCEED
THE WHAT THE SYSTEM IS DO
STATEWIDE -- WE HAVE THAT SAME
ME JUST LIKE EVERY OTHER
REGIONAL CENTER DOES.
THE LACK THE RESOURCES LACK THE
ACTUAL PEOPLE LACK ENOUGH PEOPLE
TO GO AROUND TO SERVE THOSE
CHALLENGING FOLKS -- THE GOOD
NEWS IS EVERYONE SAID AS WE ARE
SMALL COMMUNITY WE DO WORK
TOGETHER WE DO FIGURE IT OUT KID
BY KID ADULT BY ADULT HUMAN BY
HUMAN.
AND SO I THINK IN MANY WAYS WERE
LEADING THE STATE ON SOME OF THE
CREATIVE THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE
TO ENSURE PEOPLE STAY IN THEIR
COMMUNITY IN THEIR HOME.
IN SUPPORTED LIVING AND DON'T
END UP IN A LARGE CONGREGATE
CARE OUTSIDE OF OUR COMMUNITY --
BUT WE NEED HELP.
YOU KNOW.
THERE'S ONLY ONE ME.
AND THERE'S ONLY SIX AGENCIES.
THEY ARE THE SAME VENDORS SERVE
THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM THAT
SERVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THE SPUR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH.
THE ALL OF THE CONTRACTING
FUNDERS IN OUR COMMUNITY.
BY SERVICES FROM THE SAME SIX
COMPANIES THAT'S ALL THERE IS.
AND AND THEY ARE A HUGE INCREASE
FROM JUST TEN YEARS AGO WHEN WE
ONLY HAD.
ONE SO -- CAPTAIN IS IMPERATIVE
PLEASE CONTINUE TO SUPPORTING
CAPTAIN -- I THINK WHEN IT YOUR
OTHER MEETINGS YOU PROBABLY
HEARD.
ABOUT ON CAPTAIN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN CAPTAIN WITH FOR THE
SELF A SYSTEM.
BECAUSE WE DID START IN THE
SCHOOLS WE DID START WITH EARLY
INTERVENTION WE DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THE CHILDREN ARE HAVING
INCLUSIVE ENVIRONMENTS.
AND REALLY LEARNING AND LEAVING
SCHOOL WITH ACTUAL SKILLS UNDER
THEIR BELT.
BUT NOW IS SOME THERE'S SOME
TIME UNDER IT NOW WE HAVE PEOPLE
EXITING THE SCHOOL SYSTEM.
WE HAVE PEOPLE WITH AUTISM HAVE
COME UP ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM OR AGING OUT.
AND THE ADULTS SERVICE MODEL MAY
OR MAY NOT BE PREPARED TO SERVE
THEM IN THE MANNER THAT THEY
EXPECT A MANNER THAT THEY
DESERVE.
OR SPECIFIC NEEDS BEING MET
BECAUSE OF AUTISM.
AND SO NOW I THINK YOU'LL HEAR
REGIONAL CENTER PLAYING A BIGGER
AND BIGGER ROLE.
IN -- CAPTAIN THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR I JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION NINE INNING I'VE
RECOGNIZES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF LACK OF PROVIDERS.
FOR ALL OF THE STATE.
AND THE DOT DOCTOR WOULD NOT
TALK ABOUT HOW WE CREATE A MODEL
FOR CAREER.
AND CERTIFICATION FOR BETTER
WAGES AND AND WHAT NOT AND WE'RE
GONNA BE.
WORKING ON THAT TOGETHER.
WHAT'S YOUR WAIT LIST.
SO THE REASON IT DOESN'T HAVE A
WAIT LIST WE DON'T.
WOULD ALLOW IT WE DON'T BELIEVE
IN IT FIGURED OUT PERSON BY
PERSON -- WITHIN THE INSURANCE
MANDATE COMING IN THAT VERY
DESPERATE COMPLICATED THINGS I I
WORKED IN NINE OTHER STATES
BEFORE I CAME HERE AND I
ABSOLUTELY RECOGNIZE THAT IS A
GODSEND.
EVERYWHERE -- BUT MUCH LIKE
GENEVIEVE EXPLANATION OF DAY
CARES BEING ABLE TO YOU KNOW
TAKE THE EASIER CHILD.
WELL IF YOU'RE GOING TO BE
FUNDED INSURANCE COMPANY -- OR
THE REGIONAL CENTER THAN PEOPLE
WITH SEVERE NEEDS PEOPLE WITH
SEVERE CHALLENGES ARE LESS
LIKELY TO BE SIR.
BECAUSE I HAVE NEVER ENDING
REFERRALS FOR LITTLE PEOPLE WHO
NEED SERVICES RIGHT NOW SO
UNFORTUNATELY OUR POPULATIONS
ARE COMPETING AGAINST EACH OTHER.
FOR SERVICES I DON'T HAVE A WAIT
LIST BUT I DEFINITELY HAVE
PEOPLE WHO SERVED. TO HAVE --
HOURS AND HOURS WRAP THEM IN
NEED FOR COMPETENCY TO GO WITH
THAT ADEQUACY.
I DON'T HAVE ANYONE WHO IS GOING
WITHOUT.
BUT I AM MAKING SHIFT.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
SO I WOULD LOVE TO TO YOUR LIST
OF UNDERSERVED.
SO WE DON'T CALL IT AWAY.
AND ANOTHER WAS I APPRECIATE ALL
OF YOUR EFFORTS.
HAVING THE KNOWLEDGE OF HOW.
DESPAIRED OF CARE.
WE CAN BE MORE HELPFUL THAT'S
WHEN THE PROCESS WE'RE GOING
THROUGH AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
CANDOR.
AGAIN WE NEED TO KNOW.
AND WITH THE CHILD CARE
SITUATION AND ALSO -- ABA OR ANY
OTHER SERVICES THAT OUR PEOPLE
ARE HAVING.
LESS THAN YOU WOULD DESIRE.
AS THE ADMINISTRATOR OF THAT.
WE WOULDN'T WE NEED TO KNOW IS
HOW WE CAN DO THAT BUT ONE OF
THE GOOD THINGS SOME REALLY GOOD
NEWS AND WE FOUND WITH MAY
REVISE.
WAS THAT THE GOVERNOR IGNORE AND
THE BRIDGE FUNDING.
ABSOLUTELY BILLION DOLLARS.
GOING FORWARD -- AND SO.
WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN.
USE AS AN EXPENDITURE PLAN
THROUGH THE DDS OUT TO THE
REGIONAL CENTERS.
AS NOT ONE YOU KNOW WE'RE IN A
KIND OF ONE OUT OF THE BOX YEAH
YOU KNOW KIND OF THINKING SO.
I WOULD SAY THAT THAT IS RIGHT
BECAUSE REGIONAL STRENGTH.
OUT OF THE BOX -- WE ARE
CONSTANTLY CREATING THINGS AT
THE PERSON LEVEL FOR THE PERSON
SO THAT THEIR NEEDS ARE MET --
BUT NO WE NEED MORE SPANISH
SPEAKING STAFF WE NEED A CAREER
PATH FROM THE HIGH SCHOOLS TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO THE B.
C. B. A OR THE EDUCATION OR
CLINICAL PROGRAM -- WITH WORLD
WE HAVE -- DIFFERENT NEEDS --
BUT NO LESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE
PRESERVATION I LOVE YOUR PASSION
THANK.
GOD.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU.
YOU TALKED ABOUT -- THE STRENGTH
WHEN THE STRINGS OF OF BEING --
THE AREA IS THAT OUT OF THE BOX
DO YOU FEEL IN ANY WAY THAT --
YOU'RE CONSTRAINED BY SOME OF
THE RULES AND REGULATIONS I MEAN.
DO YOU DO YOU FEEL YOU HAVE THE
AUTONOMY TO DO WHAT IT IS TODAY
BUT YOU WANT TO DO I NEED ON A
PERSON BY PERSON BASIS OR IS
THERE A ARE THE CHALLENGES OF
FLEXIBILITY WE OFTEN FIND
GOVERNMENT THAT.
THEIR STRINGS ATTACHED TO
EVERYTHING AND I MEAN ANSWER
THAT CAREFULLY I I'VE WORKED
WITH OTHER REGIONAL CENTERS --
AND I DID EXPERIENCE THAT IN
OTHER REGIONAL CENTERS I DON'T
EXPERIENCE THAT HERE.
THE THIS COMMUNITY IS DIFFERENT --
WE DO SIT DOWN AND GO HOW DO WE
FIX THIS WHERE WE FIND SOMEBODY
WHO CAN -- THE CLINICIAN IN
HOUSE TEACH THAT.
OF WHO CAN ADJUST AND RISE TO
THE OCCASION AND THANKFULLY ARE
MANY ALWAYS DOES -- WE ALSO HAVE
A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT VALUE
SYSTEM RIGHT WE WE DON'T PUT
PEOPLE INSTITUTIONS WE SERVE
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOME IN THEIR
FAMILY THAT IS.
THAT IS OUR VISION AND THAT IS
OUR BELIEF AND BECAUSE THAT IS
SHARED WITH OUR PARTNERS IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND AND WE ALL YOU
KNOW KIND OF LOT OLD HIPPIES
MOVED UP HERE WAY BACK WHEN --
WE DO SERVE PEOPLE RIGHT WHERE
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE NO MATTER
WHAT IT TAKES.
AND MY EXPERIENCE IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE WERE LIKE WELL NO
WE DON'T DO THAT -- THERE'S A
CALF OR THERE'S A SPECIAL PLACE
FOR THAT.
DON'T DO IT HERE IT IS PERSON
CENTERED IT IS PERSON BY PERSON --
AND WE'RE LUCKY IN THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO PULL IT OFF SO FAR.
BUT AS THE THE BUBBLE FOR LACK
OF A BETTER WORD -- COMES UP
THROUGH THE SYSTEM THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE WITH
SEVERE AND CHALLENGING NEEDS --
PEOPLE DON'T COMMUNICATE LIKE
YOU AND I DO ARE ALL STILL IN
SCHOOL RIGHT NOW -- THEY'RE
THEY'RE COMING UP THROUGH MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND THE WAVE BEHIND THEM
IS JUST HIGHER IT'S IT'S NOT
LESSER.
AND WE YES THE REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM IN THE ADULT SERVICE
PROVIDER SYSTEM HALF TO GEAR UP.
TO SERVE YOU KNOW IN
EXPONENTIALLY LARGER AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN SCHOOLS.
WHO NEED HOUSING MANY JOBS IN IN
OUR MAKE INTERNAL TURNED OF
COMMUTE XIN?
ANY PLACE TO GO AND PEOPLE TO DO
AND SUPPORT STAFF TO DO IT AND
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TO GO
AROUND.
WELL I JUST WANT.
WE I WANT TO BE SURE THAT WE
ALLOW YOU THE FLEXIBILITY TO TO
DO THE JOB IN THE WAY THAT OUR
REGION ABSOLUTELY NEEDS THIS.
SURE RICK CAN GIVE YOU A LIST I
JUST.
REAL QUICK. ONE RISK.
THAT HAS BEEN PROBLEMATIC IN
HELPING HER ACHIEVE WHAT SHE'S
LOOKING AT IS TO PROVIDE ROUND
THE CLOCK SUPPORT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE UNDER THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN AND WISH TO LIVE
WITH.
FAMILIES ARE LIVE AT HOME AND
NOT GO TO A GROUP HOME.
OUR ABILITY TO USE SOMETHING
SUCH AS A SUPPORTER LIVING
SERVICE IS RESTRICTED FOR ONLY
EIGHTEEN AND ABOVE.
AND SO THEREFORE OUR ABILITY TO
TRY TO ACCESS THE NUMBER OF
CLINICIANS TO PROVIDE THE RIGHT
PACKED SUPERVISION SKILLS
TRAINING AND SUPPORT.
I WAS VERY STRETCH WHEN KIM'S
REFERENCING THE SIX AGENCIES
THAT TO WE HAVE TO PULL FROM TO
DO AROUND THE CLOCK SO THAT IS
ONE AREA IN TERMS OF
GOVERNMENTAL REGULATION.
THAT HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE THAT
WE SIT TOGETHER WE STRING APART.
THAT IS ONE REGULATION.
I THINK AND OTHER REGIONAL
CENTERS -- OTHER SYSTEMS I THINK
IT OTHER SYSTEMS -- THERE ARE
CHOICES THAT THOSE -- OFFICIALS
HAVE THAT WE WOULDN'T SHE IS BUT
WE ALSO DON'T HAVE RIGHTS WE
DON'T SEND PEOPLE OUT OF THE
AREA WE DON'T SEND PEOPLE TO
LOCK FACILITIES WE DON'T HAVE
NON PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
WE ONLY HAVE SIX NON PUBLIC
AGENCIES -- I THINK THERE ARE
FIFTY IN THE IN THE BAY AREA I
USED TO WORK FOR YOU SEVERAL OF
THEM AND WITH MANY OF THEM.
NONE OF THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
EXISTS IN OUR FOR COUNTIES.
AND I WOULDN'T CHOOSE TO PUT
SOMEBODY IN A LOCKED FACILITY
AND WITH THAT IS NOT A BELIEF
SYSTEM HERE.
BUT KNOW THAT ANOTHER REGIONAL
CENTER COULD MAKE THAT CHOICE
AND MIGHT OF THAT -- SERVICE
AVAILABLE TO THEM AND WE DON'T
WE JUST SIMPLY HAVE TO SOLVE IT
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IN TIME IN OR GENDER THAT WE'RE
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
AND THIS IS WHERE WE HEAR FROM
YOU.
SO LOVE YOU TO COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE IF YOU WANT TO SHARE
YOUR STORY.
TELL US YOUR NAME AND PLEASE.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME ENSURING
THAT EVERYBODY HAS A CHANCE TO
SPEAK.
LET ME ACOSTA A COUPLE MINUTES
EACH AND IF WE DO HAVE MORE TIME --
GOING FORWARD.
AND WE ADDRESS THAT WE CAN HAVE
YOU COME BACK UP IN AND ADDED.
TO IN ADDITION.
SO THANK YOU AND PLEASE STEP UP
TO THE PODIUM AND SHARE WITH US
YOUR CHALLENGES OR YOUR
HAPPINESS SEWER.
HOW THINGS ARE GOING IN YOUR
LIFE?
THANK YOU SO PLEASE TAKE YOUR
NAME IN THE SENATE -- MY NAME IS
ANDREA Q..
ONE AM -- COMMUNITY NUMBER THAT --
PROVIDE SUPPORT. TO THE
COMMUNITY.
AND SPANISH SPEAKING BILINGUAL
BICULTURAL.
N..
I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT -- WHAT'S.
BEING WORKING WHAT -- IN
REACHING OUT THE THOSE WHO --
ONE ON THE FAR END OF THE NEED
THOSE WHO ARE THE MINORITY --
REGIONAL CENTER HAS PROVIDED --
WITH THEIR OUTREACH -- DIVERSE
YEAH RICH FUNDING HAS BEEN ABLE
TO PROVIDE.
SERVICES TO THOSE WHO ARE
SPANISH SPEAKING -- DOING THE
PARENT SUPPORT GROUP.
FACILITATING THOSE -- IN THE
SPANISH SPEAKING COMMUNITY.
AND BEING ABLE TO SUPPORT AND
EDUCATE AND ENCOURAGE AND GIVE
HOPE. TO THOSE WERE -- MOSTLY
AFRAID.
AND ARE.
FEARFUL OF COMING OUT.
INVITED FAMILIES AND ENCOURAGE
THEM. TO COME HERE AND SPEAK.
AND I TOLD THEM I ONCE STAND
WITH THEM.
TOO TRANSLATION NEEDED -- BUT
FEAR IS THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
THAT WE ENCOUNTER.
IN THIS COMMUNITY AND IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF A SOMEHOW IT OKAY
PROFESSIONAL COMES IN AND TRIES
TO GIVE THEM HOPE -- IT'S IT'S
NOT ENOUGH -- REGIONAL CENTER
HAS DONE A FANTASTIC.
JOB AND AND IN TRYING TO PROMOTE --
AND HOW -- TO THOSE COMMUNITIES
AND THE THROUGH THE RADIO AT
GOING TO COLLEGE AND GIVING
AWARENESS TO THE COMMUNITY YOU
MENTIONED SOMETHING ABOUT --
BUILDING AN EDUCATIONAL PATH --
WE'RE DOING IT FROM THE FROM THE
BASELINE BRINGING AWARENESS --
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME AND WE
REPRESENT INCLUDE.
JEFF POCKET ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR REACHING FOR
INDEPENDENCE.
I WE ARE AN ADULT DAY PROGRAM --
CURRENTLY REGION FOR
INDEPENDENCE OPERATES -- THREE
COMMUNITY DO YOU CARE LICENSED
FACILITIES AND HUMBLE AND DONOR
COUNTY.
I'M I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S COME OUT IN TODAY'S
MEETING IS THAT THERE IS REALLY
NO ONE SIZE FITS ALL FOR ANY
SERVICES OFFERED UP -- THERE'S A
NEED FOR EVERYTHING THERE'S A
NEED FOR DAYZ SUPPORT THERE'S A
NEED FOR DAY PROGRAM THERE'S A
NEED FOR SUPPORTED LIVING -- I
THINK AS THE VENDOR OR A AS A
SERVICE PROVIDERS PERSPECTIVE
WHICH I'VE YOU KNOW I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY WITH
YOU BALLS AND TO SHARE THAT --
IT CAN'T BE ONE SIZE ALL WHEN IT
COMES TO FUNDING THAT YOU THERE --
FOR ME AS AS A AS A BUSINESS
PERSON IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT A
REGIONAL CENTER HAS THE OPTION
TO HAVE THE NEGOTIATED RATE TO
PROVIDE.
A FUNDING LEVELS IT CAN SUPPORT --
THE BUSINESS AT HAND.
THE RATE STUDY MODELED IT'S BEEN
PUT FORWARD TO LEGISLATURE I
THINK HAS SOME -- GEN AND IT'S
IT'S BEEN FROM.
AT A RATE OF SIX HUNDRED
SUSTAINABLE -- DOT WOULD PUT OUT
OF BUSINESS AS A CARE LESSONS
PROVIDER.
I THINK HAVING A NEGOTIATED RATE.
GIVES RESOURCE CENTER THE OPTION
OR THE AVAILABILITY -- TO PAY
FOR A SERVICE THAT SHOWS
OUTCOMES.
AND IF IT'S ONE FLAT RATE.
YOU'RE GONNA GET THE SAME
OUTCOME EVERY SINGLE TIME THANK
YOU -- FOR THAT REMINDER AND I
COULD GO ON FOR A LONG TIME IN
IN AND I HAVE SURE THAT WAS YOU
BUT I DO THINK THAT -- BY
LIMITING NOT A BILL.
THE LEADER FUND PROGRAMS PUTS
OUR CLIENTS AT RISK I'M
IMPRISONMENT YOU KNOW IN
ADEQUATE SITUATIONS.
UNDERFUNDED THE STATE HAS UNDER
FUNDED HUMAN SERVICES FOR YEARS
BECAUSE OF SAVED MILLIONS IF NOT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
ON THIS IS NOT THE TIME TO GO
BACKWARDS ISN'T THE TIME TO MOVE
FORWARD.
AND WE REALLY HAVE TO HAVE
ADEQUATE FUNDING TO PROVIDE
THESE SERVICES THANK YOU
[INAUDIBLE]
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS DAVID HAMMER TO AND I
AM NOT -- INDIVIDUAL TO
DISABILITY THAT LIVES IN THE
COMMUNITY.
AND ONE OF THE HUGE INSTEAD I'VE
HEARD AND I'VE ACTUALLY
WITNESSED -- WE NEED CHANGE AT
THE STATE LEVEL.
ASK THE GLEE ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES -- TO FINANCES FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AS IT WAS
BROUGHT UP.
LIKE MYSELF I LIVE IN A ONE
BEDROOM APARTMENT WHERE I'M
PAYING ALMOST SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND LOW INCOME.
AND EVEN WEST EMPLOYMENT I'M
LUCKY TO MAKE IT THROUGH.
THERE HAS TO BE CHANGE WHEN IT
COMES TO THE FINANCES FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES.
AND HONESTLY WE ALSO NEED TO
START BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
IF YOU KNOW WE NEED MORE MONEY
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO START HOPING
FUND WHAT WE WANT WE CAN'T JUST
GO.
IN THE REGIONAL CENTER WARS CCS
AND SAY.
HEY I WANT THIS.
WE NEED TO BE PART OF THE VOICE
THAT SAYS THIS IS WHAT WE WANT
THIS IS HOW WE'RE GOING TO HELP
GET IT.
WE PUT TOO MUCH BURDEN ON THE
STATE.
WITH NO HELP [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
WELL SAID MY FRIEND THANK.
THE MIKE THE STATE YOUR NAME.
THE MORNING.
HI.
MY NAME IS KATIE YOU BIRTH.
AND I LIVE IN EUREKA I AN
ARTISTIC.
AND I ALSO WORK FULL TIME -- FOR
H. CAR. ONE IS THE SUPPORT
AGENCIES YOUR AND I LOVE IT ENDS.
THE WHAT I MEANT TO SAY IS THAT --
A LOT.
OF I'VE HEARD A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT.
EARLY INTERVENTION I THINK
THAT'S PROBABLY A GOOD THING.
BUT A LOT OF TIMES WHEN PEOPLE
ARE TALKING ABOUT EARLY
INTERVENTION THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT TRYING TO GET KIDS. TO GET
TO THE POINT WHERE THEY'LL BE
MORE LIKE ME.
AND I STILL HAVE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS WITH GETTING THE
SERVICES THAT I NEED
[INAUDIBLE]
AND LAKE.
THE REGIONAL CENTER HERE.
AND THE AGENCIES THAT WORK WITH
THE REGIONAL CENTER.
DO A REALLY GOOD. ONE OF THINGS
BUT THERE'S ALSO.
A LOT THERE ARE.
THEY ARE UNDERSTAFFED AND THERE
ARE A LOT OF THINGS [INAUDIBLE]
THE CAN BE PROBLEMS JUST -- JUST
IN TERMS OF THINGS LIKE.
HAVING SERVICES AVAILABLE AT
TIMES THAT WORK WITH SOMEONE WHO
WHO DOES WORK FULL TIME.
SUPPORTING SOMEONE FIND WORK IS
GREAT.
AND THEN ALSO.
SO MUCH TROUBLE GETTING THINGS
SCHEDULE BUT I NEED SCHEDULED IN
A WAY THAT THE I DO THE THEY
WORK AROUND MY JOB [INAUDIBLE]
AND I DON'T KNOW.
LIKE I SAID THERE'S THINGS THAT
WE DO REALLY REALLY WELL HERE.
BUT THERE WE ARE AND LIKE ALL
THE SERVICES ARE UNDERSTAFFED
AND THERE'S DEFINITELY SOME ROOM
FOR IMPROVEMENT THERE -- THANK
YOU.
AND PLEASE SHARE WITH US YOUR
NAME.
I AM MY NAME IS JAMEL CHORUS IN --
I'M JOHN BINGE.
AND I'M I'M AN ARTIST IN --
WHOLE COUNTY AND I DO A LOT OF
OUR AND APART TREACHERY --
DISLIKE YOUR HER PUT THE WITH
THE PROGRAMS AND I'M.
SO -- I'VE I'VE HAD ALLIED
TRAINING AND LEARNING ABOUT
BEING A TEACHER BECAUSE I WAS
LIKE ONE OF MY DREAMS -- WHEN I
WAS A KID AND AND TO BE AN ART
TEACHER AND?
HELP OTHER PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF
WITH A DISABILITY -- STRIFE AND
BE.
AS OF THEMSELVES AND I'VE BEEN
DOING THAT.
RECENTLY A CALL THIS PLACE
CALLED GETTING GROUND NOT BEEN
TEACHING THERE.
AND EVERY DAY EVERY I'M NOT
EVERYDAY BUT LIKE EVERY FRIDAY
THEY TEACH THEIR YOU SEE BUDGETS
SMILES AND ENDS WILL YOU LIKE.
REALLY HIGH CONFIDENCE IN
THEMSELVES.
THERE'S THIS ONE LADY THAT --
HER NAME IS TAMMY AND SHE'S
ALWAYS IT'S HARD TODAY'S ARE
TODAY.
AND IT JUST MAKES ME FEEL GOOD
THAT THERE BE STILL CAN THE
CONFIDENCE THEY HAVE.
AND THERE ARE SPEND PROGRESSING
AND SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
HAVE.
THOSE SERVICES AND THOSE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE
DISABILITIES TO HAVE THAT. TO DO
HAVE THAT STRONG CONFIDENCE.
INTO.
INTO HAVE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THEM TO AND TO BE KEPT FOR
THEM AND IN TO BE.
SOME TO LOOK UP.
TO AND THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
I REALLY APPRECIATE.
LENA SPEAK OUT IN AND AND TELL
YOU WHAT WHAT'S GOING ON THANK
YOU GUYS CRESCENTA.
GOOD MORNING.
PLEASE SHARE WITH US YOUR MY
NAME'S ELIZABETH CORTES.
MY NAME'S ELIZABETH CORTES AND I
AM I'M I'M YEAH I WAS A MEMBER
OF THE REGIONAL CENTER BOARD I
AM A CLIENT OF THE REGIONAL
CENTER.
IT BY I MAINLY CAME HERE TODAY
TO TALK ABOUT THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS IN THE FUNDS FOR
SPECIAL OLYMPICS.
I'M A BIG TIME -- I'M A BIG TIME
SWIMMER AND WE HAVE.
WE HAVE A CHIP TO NEVADA COMING
UP AND WE REALLY NEED.
WE WOULD REALLY LIKE. TO BE ABLE
TO DO WITH THE TRAVELING AND AND
AND SINCE THE FIRST TIME I'VE
SPOKEN FRIEND OF A WHEN TWO
PEOPLE BUT YEAH -- WILL.
WE ARE MAINLY FUNDED THROUGH --
I BELIEVE IT'S THE REGIONAL
CENTER BUT I'M NOT SURE -- I
THINK WE GET A LOT OF OUR FUNDS
FROM DONATIONS AND I JUST GOT
BACK FROM A SWEAT FROM SWIMMING
AND I REALLY ENJOY IT AND I HOPE
THAT WHAT IT CAN BE CONTINUED --
SO -- WE HAVE A TRIP COMING UP
NEXT WEEK -- AND I REALLY HOPE
IT.
IT STAYS THAT WE CAN KEEP IT
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT JUST ME THAT
ENJOYS IT BUT THERE'S HUNDREDS
OF OTHER PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT.
THAT OUR THAT ALSO ENJOY IT AND
IT'S PRETTY MUCH SOMETHING THAT
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
IN JULY AND I'M ONE OF THEM I
HAVE.
I HAVE A LEARNING DISABILITY
[INAUDIBLE]
AND ALSO I HAVE A HAVE --
MEDICAL ISSUES TOO BUT THOSE
AREN'T STOPPING ME FROM DOING
WHAT I LOVE TO DO THE BACK DO
MOST -- SOL THAT'S WHY I CAME
HERE TODAY WAS JUST TO MAINLY
TALK ABOUT THE SPECIAL OLYMPICS
AND AND THE THANKS FOR LISTENING.
THANK YOU.
MYSELF WAS WERE ABLE TO SECURE.
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS FOUR
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR
SPECIAL OLYMPICS AND FUNDING FOR
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SO AN ADDITIONAL TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THIS YEAR BUT WE'RE
HOPING.
FOR THREE SO SPECIAL EXHIBIT A
VOLUNTEER FOR FIFTEEN YEARS AT
THE GAMES.
GOOD MORNING WELL GOOD A GOOD
AFTERNOON ACTUALLY MY NAME IS
GREGORY CORDIS AND I'M THE LAST
COURT ISSUE HERE FROM TODAY.
THIS IS PAMELA KING ARI.
AND SHE'S A REGIONAL CENTER
CLIENT.
I HAVE. ONE MORE REGIONAL CENTER
CLIENT AT HOME WITH MY WIFE.
I HIS NAME IS CURTIS RYAN.
HOW WE HAD A RETOOL CENTER?
UP UNTIL OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR
SINCE HIS BIRTH.
AND HE WAS PLACED IN THE BAY
AREA.
BY RC RC.
FINALLY.
TOOK ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF --
MY WIFE -- RAN A A FAMILY CARE
HOME FOR YEARS.
STARTED AS A FOSTER PARENT.
I AM AN ENGINEER I WORKED IN
MANUFACTURING.
COULDN'T LEARN MANDARIN.
SIDE YEAH -- SO MY MAIN REASON
FOR BEING HERE IS TO GIVE YOU
SOME MORE INFORMATION ABOUT OUR
C. R. C. -- WHEN WE FIRST CAME
HERE? TO HUMBOLDT COUNTY FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA [INAUDIBLE]
I'M GETTING.
INTO THEIR SYSTEM WAS RELATIVELY
SMOOTH.
BUT RECENTLY IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS AS FAR AS THEIR MANAGERIAL.
EXPERTISE I WOULD SAY A COMPARED
TO MANY OTHER PLACES.
I'VE WORKED.
AND WORK WITH.
IT'S BEYOND PART UNDER PAR -- TO
PLACE DILLON.
I HAD TO CONTACT.
YOU KYRA.
I I THINK IS DOCTOR BLOOM.
BLOOMBERG.
IS THE HEAD DOWN THERE.
AND CAN YOU SHAKE UP THE PEOPLE
IN OUR C. R. C. TO GET THE BALL
ROLLING SO WE CAN GET DILLON
PLACED AND CURRENTLY WE'RE
WORKING ON PLACING -- CURTIS
RYAN WHO WAS AT HOME WITH MY
WIFE AND THE NURSE -- MY WIFE'S
IN POOR HEALTH.
I AM.
SEVENTY TWO SO WE NEED TO MOVE
HIM ON I THINK.
YOU JUST NEED MORE INFORMATION
OR MORE FEEDBACK FROM THE TWENTY
ONE REGIONAL CENTERS AS FAR AS
THEIR MANAGERIAL PERFORMANCE.
FOR EXAMPLE PAM FOR THREE YEARS
DIDN'T SEE -- A WORKER.
WE DIDN'T SEE OVER THREE YEARS.
NORMALLY YET TO VISIT OUR HOME
AND AND STARTED IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY THAT'S ABOUT ALL
I INFORMATION I CAN GIVE YOU AYE
I LEFT MY PHONE NUMBER.
ON THE SIGN IN SHEET.
AND MY ADDRESS IF YOU WISH TO
CONTACT ME.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING TIME TODAY --
SICK IF I CAN'T.
WE SHARE THIS UNIT.
HELLO MY NAME IS BRANDON MENACE
AND I WORK WITH H. CARS
COMPREHENSIVE CAREER SERVICES AS
A JOB COACH.
I CAME UP HERE TODAY TO SPEAK
MORE ABOUT -- MY AGENCY AND WHAT
I DO AS A JOB COACH.
CURRENTLY I WORK WITH ABOUT
SEVEN INDIVIDUALS EACH RANGING
FROM THE AGES OF THEIR LOWER
TWENTY IS -- TO LOTHAR LOW
FIFTIES ACTUALLY.
AND EACH ONE OF THEM HAS MANY
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES SO IT'S
VERY PERSON CENTERED SUMMER --
JUST GRADUATING IN A TEST YOU
THIS.
NEXT WEEK ACTUALLY TO SOME BEING
OUT OF WORK FOR A FEW YEARS TO
SOME NEVER HAVING A JOB.
AND I DRIVE USUALLY BETWEEN --
MCKINLEY THEY'LL ALL THE WAY
DOWN FOR TWO AND WHICH IS A
DISTANCE OF THIRTY FIVE MILES.
AT LEAST -- SEVERAL TIMES A WEEK
SO THERE'S THAT.
TOO SO USUALLY DURING MY JOB BY.
RISE TO THE I AM SO RESIDENTS OR
WHATEVER THEY WISH TO ME TO HAVE
A WEEKLY CHECK INS WITH THEM.
IF THEY'RE EMPLOYED TO MEET WITH
THEIR A SUPERVISOR AT THEIR WORK
AT LEAST ONCE A WEEK TO DO
WEEKLY CHECK INS AND I ALSO A
TRY TO HELP THEM FIND.
LASTING AND MEANINGFUL JOBS IN
THE COMMUNITY.
WHILE WORKING WITH THE FABULOUS
STAFF AND SERVICE COORDINATORS
AT THE REDWOOD COAST REGIONAL
CENTER.
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE -- CAN TING
COME VIRGINIA SNODGRASS A MOTHER
STAFF LIKE KIM NASH SAID THAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM AND SIERRA
BRAGS SO THAT'S JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF A WHEN I DO AND IF I WAS
TO SPEAK AT LENGTH WE WOULD BE
HERE UNTIL -- NEXT WEEK SO AND
WE DON'T WANT THAT SO THANK.
AND I DIDN'T BRING A SLEEPING
BAG.
YES.
YOUR INPUT THIS WILL MAKE IT.
NEXT WEEK.
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF.
MY NAME IS BARB THEIR AND I WORK
FOR CALIFORNIA MENTOR AND I ALSO
COACH FOR SPECIAL OLYMPICS --
OUR AGENCY PROVIDES HOMES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DOES AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
BUT I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT A
GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT WE HAVEN'T
EVEN AS TODAY AND THAT'S THE
NONVERBAL PEOPLE.
AS DOCTOR BLOOMBERG STRAIGHT
STATED AT THE BEGINNING OF HIS
SPEECH.
WE HAVE A LOT OF MEDICAL ISSUES
ISSUES HERE IF WE HAVE A PROBLEM
WE HAVE TO GO TO SAN FRANCISCO
OR SACRAMENTO.
IT WILL ONLY TAKE A CLIENT THAT
IS NON VERBAL INTO THE HOSPITAL.
MOST OF THE TIME THEY'RE NOT
REALLY LISTENING TO WHAT WE HAVE
TO SAY.
THEY'RE JUST LOOKING AT SIGNS
AND SYMPTOMS THEY'RE NOT
LISTENING TO WHAT CARE GIVERS
ARE SAYING.
AND THEY'RE KIND OF LIKE PUSHING
US TALK TO THE SIDE -- I HAD A
CLIENT THAT WAS HOSPITALIZED.
TWENTY ONE DAYS OF THIRTY DAYS
FOR CONSTIPATION.
AND I KEPT FIGHTING WITH THE
DOCTORS AND FIGHTING WITH THE
DOCTORS THAT THEY NEEDED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS SHE IS NON
VERBAL.
SHE'S NON AMBULATORY.
AND SHE IS A JOY TO BE AROUND.
AND WHEN THE DOCTORS DON'T
LISTEN TO US.
THE CLIENTS ARE NOT GETTING THE
CARE THAT THEY NEED.
AND I KNOW THAT THAT'S NOT JUST
SOMETHING THAT'S HERE LOCALLY
THAT IT'S A SYSTEMIC PROBLEM.
BUT THAT NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT
TO WIN NONVERBAL CLIENTS ARE IN
THE HOSPITAL.
THEY NEED TO BE STE TREATED WITH
THE SAME DIGNITY AND RESPECT
ISSUE.
AND THEY NEED TO BE HEARD
WHOEVER'S TALKING FOR THEM THEY
NEED TO BE HAVE THEIR VOICE.
THANK YOU.
A BRAND SHERMAN -- I'M AN ARTIST
I'M AT THE PROGRAM MANAGER AT
TRAJECTORY -- I SUPPORT ARTISTS
MANY COUPLE THE ARTISTS -- I
KNOW THERE THERE'S SOME TALK
ABOUT THE FUNDING AND STUFF LIKE
THAT I DON'T YOU KNOW I I JUST
WANT TO IF IF YOU ARE LOOKING AT
SORT OF I I KNOW THE THE THING
THAT THEY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IN
TERMS OF THAT IS LIKE.
WE TRY TO BE WE ARE PERSON
CENTERED.
SO A LOT OF THE STUFF THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT NOW.
SEEMS TO BE VERY SORT OF LIKE I
DON'T KNOW HOW IT RELATES TO
THAT.
SO WHEN YOU I I JUST I JUST ASK
THAT YOU CONSIDER THAT WE DO
THIS ON A PERSON TO PERSON BASIS
THAT DIAGNOSTICS ARE NOT A ISSUE
LIKE IDEAL WITH.
AN ARTIST AS THAT HUMAN BEING.
SO.
I'VE I'VE.
I'M HOPING THAT IS A A A PRIMARY
CONCERN IS THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH HUMAN BEINGS AND I DON'T I
MEAN.
FROSTED UNTIL WITH ARTISTS TO
I'M AN ARTIST IT'S WE'RE ALSO
THAT'S A MARGINAL THING AS WELL
SO I ALSO WANT TO ADVOCATE FOR
THE ARTS AS A LEGITIMATE WAY TO
BE EMPLOYED.
SO AS AN ARTIST AND AS AN ARTIST
MYSELF WE ARE WORKING WITH --
THE PIPP PROGRAM THAT PAID
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM WHERE'D
DEVELOPING SKILLS [INAUDIBLE]
HILL SAID [INAUDIBLE]
WHO THAT?
THANK YOU SEE THAT THERE IS
[INAUDIBLE]
I SEE.
RIGHT NOT.
WAY.
SO AM I WANT TO SAY THAT.
THOSE SKILL SETS ARE THERE AND
WE CAN WE CAN BE UP WE CAN APPLY
THEM WITH SUPPORT A LOT OF TIMES
THAT SUPPORT.
IS IT'S LOOKED AT I I LOOKED AT
IT I LOOK AT SOMETHING SOMEONE
SAID THIS IS LIKE GOD'S WORK I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
IT'S A SKILLED IT'S A SKILL SET
WE ALL DEVELOP SKILL SETS AND
MISSION [INAUDIBLE]
DEVELOPS TRY.
PROGRAMS ARE SUPPORT AGENCY WITH
PEOPLE AND DEVELOPING
INDEPENDENCE.
WITH WHAT THEY WANT TO DO AS A
HUMAN BEING -- AND I KNOW THAT
THAT'S A LOT OF OF THE LACK IS
IN COORDINATION WITH HEALTH CARE
AND ALL THAT OTHER STUFF IT'S A
HOLISTIC PROBLEM.
BUT FOR ME I'M ADVOCATING FOR
THE ARTISTS ANIME BEGINNING FOR
HER SUPPORT -- FOR PROGRAMS THAT --
DEVELOP INDEPENDENCE AND DEVELOP
AGENCY SO.
I MEAN YEAH I I WHAT ARTIST YOU
THEY CAN TALK ABOUT THEIR SELF
AMONG IT'S HARD FOR THEM BUT
THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF.
HELLO MY NAME IS SUSAN HALDERMAN
MIGHT MIGHT TALKED EARLIER.
YES.
AND SHE DOES. THREE DOES NOT
SOMEONE TO SAY.
THAT.
IS DONE THEY HAVE GONE TO BATON
HELP SOPHIE -- INTO THE HIGH
SCHOOL ATMOSPHERE -- FOR WE
NEEDED HER TO HAVE AN IEP AND IT
WAS REALLY DIFFICULT.
COUNSELORS CAME IN AN OFFICE SO
I'M JUST SAYING IS THAT --
THEY'VE HELPED IN THE ART FIELD
BUT ALSO THE FAMILY TO THE
COUNSELORS AND THE PEOPLE THAT
THEY HAVE IN THEIR HAVE REALLY --
OF WE NEED THEM.
HI MY RUN.
HOW I CAN ONLY PROCESS THAT?
EVERYBODY IN THE OFFICE THERE'S
SOMEONE THERE TO HELP OVER
SEVERAL ASPECTS THAT SHE NEEDS
HELP WITH.
AND WERE VERY VERY GRATEFUL THAT
THEY'VE BEEN THERE SO IT'S NOT
JUST ONE THING.
AT SEVERAL THINGS THAT THEY'VE.
THERE IF TO BE THERE FOR HER AND
OBVIOUSLY A VERY BIG THANK YOU.
BUT WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THOSE
FUNDING THAT THAT COMES IN FOR
THAT.
SOME THANK YOU.
I'M GLAD YOU FOUND A HELLO MY
NAME IS STEPHEN JACKSON I'M THE
OPERATIONS DIRECTOR FOR NUDE ON
SUPPORT SERVICES BUT I'M ALSO
THE RECENT APPOINTEE AS THE
VENDOR SERVICES REPRESENTATIVE --
FOR THE BOARD AT REGIONAL CENTER --
SO ONE THING I WANT TO KIND OF
TALK ABOUT IS YOU KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF TALK ABOUT THE THE
NEED FOR INCREASED FUNDING TO GO
TOWARDS VENDORS IN SUCH A BILL
ACTUALLY COMPENSATE I WANT TO
KIND OF TALK ABOUT.
WHAT THAT ACTUALLY MEANS AND
WHAT THAT DOES AND AND PART OF
THAT IS THE THE EXPECTATION THAT
GETS PUT ON US BY THE RED
BECAUSE REGIONAL CENTER I'M
THANKFUL FOR THIS?
THAT WE WE HAVE PROFESSIONALS
THEY'RE THEY'RE COMING IN
PROVIDING THE SUPPORT NUMBER
WERE EDUCATORS IN THAT THAT WERE --
MORE THAN JUST A CARE GIVER I
HATE THAT TERM A PATERNAL
QUOTATIONS JUST CARE GIVER.
BUT THAT THAT WE ARE ACTUAL
PROFESSIONALS THAT THE AMOUNT OF
TRAINING THAT MY STAFF GO
THROUGH ON A YEARLY BASIS AND ON
GOING -- WHETHER THE COMPANY AS
LAY PEOPLE ARE COMING IN -- YOU
CAN GET COLDS DEGREES OFF THE
AMOUNT OF CLASSROOM TIME I'M
PUTTING MY STAFF THROUGH.
IN IT'S EVIDENT WHEN I LOSE MY
EMPLOYEES TO PLACES LIKE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO PLACES LIKE
KNOWINGLY HIRING I'M PSYCHED
EXCELLENT BECAUSE OF
PREREQUISITES THAT COME INTO
PLAY BECAUSE OF A JOB
EXPERIENCES THAT THEY HAVE SO
IT'S NOT JUST FOR LOSING PEOPLE --
TO FAST FOOD BUSINESSES OR TO
RETAIL OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT
WE'RE LOSING IT TO THE LIGHT
FIELDS THAT ARE IN THERE BECAUSE
WE WE DO KEEP PEOPLE AT A
PROFESSIONAL LEVEL TO BE ABLE TO
DO A SERVICES OUT THERE NOW THE
PROBLEM IS IS.
HOW DO YOU END UP PROVIDING THE
THE PAY TO BE ABLE TO KEEP THOSE
EMPLOYEES ON I AT WE TAP INTO
THE THE EMOTIONAL?
OUR OUR STAFF ALL THE TIME AND
SAY.
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS BENEFICIAL
AND?
WHAT YOU'RE DOING [INAUDIBLE]
FOR START.
DOWN THE TRUST NOT BEFORE ME AND
I TALKED ABOUT THE THE TRUST
THAT GOES INTO IT'S NOW TO KEEP
THAT GOING.
AND THEN THEY LEAVE FOR
DIFFERENT JOBS AFTER THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THE PERSON
RECEIVING THE SUPPORTS.
I'M SORRY I COULDN'T KEEP THEM
NOT BECAUSE OF YOU BUT BECAUSE
THEY HAVE TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES AS WELL THEY HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A CAREER FOR
THEMSELVES AND I WOULD LOVE FOR
IN REAL OF A CAREER.
RIGHT HERE INSIDE OF THIS
SERVICE INDUSTRY TO WHERE THEY
DON'T HAVE TO GO IN AND FIND
SOMETHING ELSE YOU KNOW WHAT ALL
THEY NEED IS RIGHT HERE THE
EDUCATION THAT THEY GET THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT THEY BUILD.
THE OPPORTUNITY WITH COMMUNITY
THAT'S HERE.
THAT'S WHERE THESE PEOPLE SHOULD
BE STAYING IN AND NOT YOU KNOW
GOING TOWARDS WHERE THE MONEY
ACTUALLY FINDS THEM FOR LIKE
MINDED WORK.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING.
PLEASE THERE WAS UNITS.
MY NAME IS LAURIE OWENS AND I A
MAID DIRECT SUPPORT AND JOB
COACH FOR REACHING FOR
INDEPENDENCE.
AND I CAME HERE TO SPEAK NOT
ONLY AS A STAFF PERSON THAT
WORKS PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES.
BUT ALSO AS A FAMILY MEMBER.
I HAVE FAMILY UP IN WASHINGTON.
THAT.
DO NOT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT A LOT OF THESE PROGRAMS
PROVIDE AND UNFORTUNATELY HE'S
HAD TO GO TO DIFFERENT TYPES OF
INSTITUTIONS AND THINGS BECAUSE
NOBODY'S STARTED EARLY WITH HIM --
TO ME A LOT OF THIS IS ABOUT A
QUALITY OF LIFE EVERYBODY
DESERVES A QUALITY OF LIFE
EVERYBODY DESERVES. TO EXPLORE
THIS WORLD.
AND TO CHANGE HOW PEOPLE FEEL --
WHEN I TAKE CLIENTS OUT INTO THE
TO THE PUBLIC AND WE'RE WORKING?
PEOPLE REALIZE THAT.
THEY CAN DO A LOT OF THINGS AND
HAVING SEEN SOMEBODY GET THEIR
FIRST PAYCHECK AND BEING ABLE TO
BUY WHAT THEY WANT TO WITH THEIR
MONEY IS INCREDIBLE.
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW YOUNG
OR OLD THEY ARE YOU STILL SEE
THAT SPARK IN THEIR EYES AND I
APPRECIATE THE FUNDING THAT YOU
GIVE US BUT I THINK THE FUNDING
WOULD BE BETTER CAP WITH PEOPLE --
THAT ARE.
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE HELPING
PEOPLE TO BE MORE INDEPENDENT
BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO PAY. ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER.
THE FUNNY IS GOING TO COME
SOMEWHERE SO IF YOU KEEP IT WITH
THESE PROGRAMS -- PEOPLE CAN BE
INDEPENDENT THEY CAN LEARN
SOCIAL SKILLS THEY CAN AND
READING AND ALL KINDS OF OTHER
THINGS -- TOO TO ADD TO THE
QUALITY OF LIFE SO THAT'S
BASICALLY WHAT I WANTED TO SAY
AND I THINK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING THAT
[INAUDIBLE]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
OF THE SERVICE.
MY NAME IS KERA PONTON.
I'M A CLIENT OF REBEL BECAUSE
REGIONAL CENTER.
I'VE BEEN PART OF THE REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM SINCE HOUSE OF
FLOW GIRL AS THROUGHOUT THE
YEARS THE REGIONAL SYSTEM IN OUR
SYSTEM HAS PROVIDED ME WITH.
NUMBER SUPPORT SAYS. FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN I WAS.
EIGHTEEN I HAD SPINAL SURGERY IN
THE OF THE CARE THAT I RECEIVED.
AFTER THAT.
FROM THE THE WITH FROM AFTER A
THAT MY MY A SERVICE COORDINATOR
AT THE TIME A ED PUT IN SOME
SUPPORTS FOR ME.
AND AS I GOT OLDER A AS I COPED
WITH THAT AS PART OF MY
DISABILITY.
AND THE I AGREE WITH A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
THAT.
MOST OF OUR CLIENTS ARE ACTUALLY
DUAL DIAGNOSED.
AND I ACTUALLY ONE OF THE ONES
ARE.
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE TO DIAGNOSIS
I ACTUALLY HAVE. TO ONLY HAVE.
AN INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY I
ALSO HAVE ORTHOPEDIC
DISABILITIES [INAUDIBLE]
AND THE WHAT.
END OF OF WITH THE TWO OF
ACTUALLY COMES IN CHALLENGE A
LOT OF CHALLENGES.
POORER AT ME AS FOR LIVING
INDEPENDENT BUT I ACTUALLY.
DO LIVE INDEPENDENTLY WITH
SUPPORT IT'S THE REGIONAL CENTER
THANK YOU.
SO PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS BARBARA NELSON.
AND I'M A PROUD MOTHER OF THREE
BIRTH CHILDREN AND MANY
ADDITIONAL COME ALONG CHILDREN --
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
MY FIRST CHILD WAS BORN IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN SO I'VE
BEEN AROUND FOR AWHILE THE SAME
YEAR THAT THE LANHAM ACT PASSED.
MY DAUGHTER WAS BORN WITH DOWN
SYNDROME AT THE TIME IT WAS FOR
REFER TO AS A MONGOLOID.
THE DOCTOR SAID I WOULD BE
BETTER OFF PUTTING HER IN AN
INSTITUTION SHE WOULD NEVER
LEARN SHE WOULD NEVER GO
ANYWHERE.
THAT WAS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
NOT MY LIFE.
WHEN SHE WAS TWO YEARS OLD?
FROM THE NEW RC RC REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM.
CAME TO CS AND OUR LIVES WERE
FOREVER CHANGED.
BETWEEN RC RC AND THE COUNTY
SCHOOLS THERE WAS NO ROOM
REINVENTION AT THAT TIME LIKE
THEY HAVE NOW.
OF LIFE WAS DEFINITELY LOOKING
UP.
SO WHEN MY SON WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH AUTISM AT THE AGE OF SIX NO
OR EVEN XIN THAN EITHER.
WE KNEW WHERE TO TURN FOR HELP.
HOW MANY? FOR ALL [INAUDIBLE]
PLEASE.
I WAS ONE OF THE FIRST PIECE BY
PERSONS TO WORK FOR THE FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTER WHEN IT WAS IN
EXISTENCE HERE.
AND IT WAS VERY COLLABORATIVE
BETWEEN SCHOOLS AND REGIONAL
CENTERS.
AND FAMILY MEMBERS AND WE WERE
ABLE TO GO AS A FAMILY PERSON.
TO HAVE SOMEONE GO TO A CHILD
THEIR FAMILY WHO IS BORN WITH A
CHILD WITH.
DOWN SYNDROME.
DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM THEY HAD
ANOTHER PARENT THEIR TO MENTOR
THEM. TO HELP THEM THROUGH THE
SYSTEM THAT WAS GOING TO BECOME
THEIR LIFE.
THIS IS NOT AN MUCH ANYMORE WE
HAVE NOTHING LOCALLY FOR
FAMILIES.
SINCE THAT TIME I HAVE --
CREATED IT WAS ONE OF THE PEOPLE
TO CREATE.
A PROGRAM IN FORTUNA A VERY
SMALL PROGRAM LICENSE.
FOR THIRTEEN I'M THEIR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR.
WE ARE NOW TAKING A CUSTOM
LICENSE PLATE MET AND WORKING
THROUGH THAT SO WE CAN BE
COMPLIANCE WITH EVERYTHING THAT
IS NEEDED.
IT'S BEEN A LONG ROAD I HAVE
WATCHED SERVICES AND I'VE
WATCHED THEM GO.
THE RECESSION OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT ALMOST CRUMBLED LETTERMAN
ACT.
THE VERY ACT THAT IS MY FAMILY
SAVING GRACE ALONG WITH MANY
OTHERS.
WE HAVE WORKED TIRELESSLY TO
KEEP THINGS GOING.
WHAT IS A PROVIDER?
I AGREE WITH EVERYBODY WHO HAS
SPOKEN HERE TODAY.
WE HAVE WORKERS THAT PUTS THEIR
HEARTS INTO THE SYSTEM.
THAT THEY'RE LIVING WAGE.
THEY'RE LIVING WAGE FOR THEIR
FAMILY.
IS EIGHTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH OR LESS.
HOW MANY OF YOU CAN LIVE OFF OF
THAT?
NOT VERY MANY.
IT'S TIME.
TIME TO BRING BACK SOME
STABILITY FOR THE INDIVIDUALS WE
SUPPORT.
IT'S TIME TO STOP STAFF TURNOVER
BY GIVING OR CREATING A LIVING
WAGE WITH BENEFITS FOR THEM.
IT'S TIME FOR THE STATE TO SEE
THE CRISIS I KNOW THAT IT IS
REAL.
IT'S TIME. TO ADEQUATELY AND
FAIRLY FUND PROGRAMS.
WE CAN'T GIVE MORE.
WHEN THERE IS NO MORE TO GIVE?
WE HAVE OTHER SPEAK YES THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF.
HELLO AGAIN.
OF MILLIONS MORE CALL CLEAR IN
HERE NOW -- SPEAKING AS A DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL -- BEEN
DOING THIS WORK FOR A GOOD
NUMBER OF NUMBER YEARS NOW FOR
THE LAST. FOUR YEARS FOR A
AGENCY OR MEDIA LIVING OF
SUPPORT SERVICES WE PROVIDE.
YOUR RECENT SUPPORT SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE ALL IN.
AN INDEPENDENT SITUATION SO WITH.
ON THE ROAD IN THEIR OWN HOMES
AND AND IT'S A STRUGGLE FOR US --
MISSION STRUGGLE FOR CIVIL US
WORKERS HERE WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY
OF AN INCREASE IN OUR AREA IN A
RATE INCREASE.
FOR ABOUT THREE YEARS.
QUICKLY ADDRESS THAT HERE AND
AND MUSTAFA YOU KNOW I THINK
IT'S TIME FOR THAT TO BE.
REALLY SERIOUSLY LOOKED AT AND
PROVIDING YOU KNOW DOING WHAT
YOU CAN DOES BEST TO PROVIDE US
A LIVING WAGE FOR LESS SUPPORT
PROVIDERS -- FROM A DAY TO DAY
BASIS FROM CERTAIN THINGS YOU'RE
SETTING UP OF DOING OF SEVEN
POINT MENTAL SCHEDULE SCHEDULING
MEDICATIONS OVERSEEING A
CLIENT'S MEDICATIONS FILLING
MEDICATIONS.
MAKING SURE THINGS ARE SMALL IN
THROUGH THE FROM DOCTORS TO
PROVIDERS.
SETTING UP THEIR I. P. P.'S
THROUGH -- YOU KNOW FOR THE
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICE
COORDINATORS THE BASIC THINGS
LIKE SHOWERING CLIENTS -- YOU
CAN SURELY GET TO GROCERY STORES
MAKING SURE THEY HAVE THE PLEASE
SERVICES THAT ARE MEETING THEIR
NEEDS MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S
GOOD COMMUNICATION WITHIN
FAMILIES PROVIDING.
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS
COUNSELING IN ABOVE THESE YOU
HAVE THESE SORT OF SITUATIONS
WITH IT WITH A MEDICAL EMERGENCY
COMES UP BUT I HAVE A CLIENT --
ABOUT A YEAR AGO HAVE LITTLE IN
THE FALL -- WILL HE'S PADDED
PAST NEUROLOGICAL DAMAGE TO HIS
MEANS HE NEEDS THE IT'S
SOMETHING LIKE THAT JUSTICE
CRITICAL FALL HE'S GOING DOWN TO
SAN FRANCISCO.
WITHIN YOU KNOW MOVIES GET.
VERY MUCH WHEN HE FALLS YOU KNOW
YOU YOU'RE SETTING HIM UP HERE
YOU HAVE TO FIND STAFF IN YOUR
FOR VETTING YOU FUNDING HERE OF
GETTING A HOLD OF THE SERVICE
COORDINATORS HERE TO GET HIM
DOWN TO SAN FRANCISCO -- THAT'S
TOUGH STUFF YOU GOT TO PUT STUFF
ON THE LINE IF YOU HAVE OTHER
CLIENTS THAT YOU'RE SERVING THAT
ARE GOING TO BE NEED YOU NEED TO
FIVE STAFFING FOR THAT -- FOR
THE CLAIM FOR YOU YOU ALREADY
SERVE A ROUNDER STAFFED -- YOU
KNOW THIS IT'S NOT A FAKE
INCREDIBLY COMPETITIVE.
THERE'S A LOT OF JOBS HERE --
FOR THAT IT BUT BUT THE FAIRLY
LOW PAYING YOU HAVE MANY -- I'M
LUCKY ENOUGH TO TO BUY AGENCY TO
BE ABLE TO BE.
EMPLOYED YOU KNOW FULL TIME
THROUGH.
OF THAT BUT THAT'S NOT THE CASE
FOR A LOT OF WORKERS YOU HAVE A
LOT OF WORKERS HERE -- WHO ARE
WORKING FOR MULTIPLE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES OF SOME WORKING OFTEN
YOU HAVE A?
WORKERS WHO WERE WORKING IN DAY
PROGRAMS AND THEN THEY SPEND OUR
EVENINGS WORKING DOING.
SO LESS WORK TO MAKE ENDS MEET
SO [INAUDIBLE]
YES.
SO YES -- IF YOU YOUTH YEAH
PLEASE DO DO WHAT YOU CAN LOOK
INTO THE OTHER ROOM. THREE
ELIZABETH RATES HEARING OF THE
CHILD WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES SHE WAS REGIONAL
SINGLE CLIENT INITIALLY -- WHEN
SHE WAS AN ABOUT A YEAR OLD AND
THEN SHE LEFT THE SYSTEM WHEN
SHE WAS THREE BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T
QUALIFY SHE RE QUALIFIED AGAIN
WHEN SHE WAS?
FIVE ON WE WERE LUCKY ENOUGH TO
HAVE THE SAME SERVICE
COORDINATOR. FOR I DON'T KNOW
UNTIL SHE TURNED SEVENTEEN WHICH
WAS BEING SWAYED. FOR MAN WHO.
DIED A COUPLE YEARS BACK ON ONE
OF THE THINGS -- THAT PIECE --
ABOUT THE SERVICE COORDINATION
THAT WAS SO IMPORTANT FOR US IS
THAT LONG STANDING RELATIONSHIP
WITH SOMEONE WE TRUST.
SO KEEPING PEOPLE IN THOSE
POSITIONS AND KEEPING THIS THAT
THE RATIOS DOWN IS REALLY
IMPORTANT -- I HAVE WORKED IN A
COUPLE AGENCIES MYSELF AS YOU
KNOW I KIND OF REINVENTED MYSELF
THROUGH THE YEARS AS A PARENT --
OF CHILD WITH DISABILITIES
WHATEVER KIND OF WHAT NEEDS WERE
HERS AT THAT TIME I KIND OF
REINVENTED MYSELF.
I'VE WORKED WITH AGENCIES AND I
ALSO -- SAY THAT YOU KNOW WE
NEED TO LOOK AT PAY.
AND BENEFITS -- THOSE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT -- THE OTHER PIECE
THAT I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT I FOUND I'M IN
WORKING WITH SEVERAL AGENCIES IS --
THERE'S REALLY NOT A IN AN
OVERALL QUALITY ASSURANCE -- FOR
AGENCIES IN THE DIDN'T ARISE
SYSTEM THERE'S THE SERVER THE
THE ESSAY ARE A SPECIAL INCIDENT
REPORTS THAT GO THROUGH THE
REGIONAL CENTER AND UP THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES.
BUT THERE'S NO OVERALL QUALITY
CONTROL -- THE YOU DO HAVE THE
STATE COUNCIL OF DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES WHO IS DOING SOME
WORK IN THAT NOW -- BUT I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO LOOK QUALITY
CONTROL AND THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE
THAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT WITH
AND SELF DETERMINATION COMING IN.
TO PLAY IS THAT WE'RE EVEN GOING
TO HAVE LESS ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
SOME OF THOSE SERVICES SO I WANT
DOT COM. TO BE THOUGHT ABOUT --
SO ANYWAY THOSE ARE A FEW OF THE
THINGS THAT I FELT REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO KNOW THANK
YOU SHE SHARING THAT WITH US.
GREETINGS AGAIN I'M KIM NASH I
DID WANT TO BRING UP ONE MORE
I'M VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC THAT
HAS TO DO WITH THE NUMBER OF
CASES AROUND SUSPECTED ABUSE.
WHETHER IT'S FINANCIAL NEGLECT
SEXUAL OR PHYSICAL.
AND ASK -- FOR THE NEW SOLUTIONS
OR SOME WAY THAT WE CAN SEE
GREATER RESPONSE FROM PROTECTIVE
SERVICES FROM OUR POLICE
AGENCIES TO DO A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATIONS.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY WHEN THERE
ARE OUR FINDINGS TO TO PROSECUTE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WE FREQUENTLY
DO YOU SEE AND MAKE REFERRALS
FOR PROTECTIVE SERVICES -- AND
SOMETIMES THOSE CASES ARE QUITE
OVER.
OF THE ABUSE WE'VE SEEN.
HOWEVER THERE IS A PROSECUTION
THERE IS A FOLLOW UP AND THEN
THOSE INDIVIDUALS GO BACK INTO
THE SERVICE SYSTEM.
WELL WE CAN WATCH FOR OUR
SERVICES.
WE CAN'T WATCH FOR ALL DEPENDENT
AND IT CONCERNS ME BY THE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS THAT DO GET
REFERRALS FOR SUSPECTED ABUSE.
THAT AREN'T GETTING THE FOLLOW
UP AND ARE GETTING THE
INTERVIEWS AND THAT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
ARE OFTEN SEEN AS POOR REPORTERS
WHEN IN FACT THEY'RE NOT POOR
REPORTERS THEY JUST MAY HAVE
DIFFICULTIES IN THE WAY THEY
VERBALIZE WHAT HAS HAPPENED.
I WANTED TO BRING THAT TO YOUR
ATTENTION BECAUSE IT IS A
SERIOUS ISSUE.
THAT CONCERNS ALL OF US WHO ARE
HERE IN THE SYSTEM.
EVERY DAY SOME THANK YOU JUST
MEASURE WITH THE LEGISLATION
JUST ON THAT TOPIC THANK YOU
I'VE BEEN WATCHING THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M MERRY BLOCK ON BOTH THE
RESIDENTS OF HUMBLE COUNTY.
AND I'M ALSO THE DIRECTOR OF
CLIENT SERVICES WITH RED BRICK
COAST REGIONAL CENTER.
AND I KNOW THAT WE'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR A LOT OF
INFORMATION FROM PEOPLE IN --
AND THE NEED FOR PROVIDER
SUPPORTS PROVIDER FUNDING WE'VE
HEARD A LITTLE BIT CAM JUST
MENTION THAT -- IN HER US IN HER
PRESENTATION.
ABOUT OVERSIGHT WE HEARD ABOUT
COLLABORATION IN THE IMPORTANCE
OF COLLABORATION BETWEEN
REGIONAL CENTERS AND OUR OUR
PARTNERS.
BUT I WANT -- TO ADVOCATE FOR
TWO IS THE OPERATIONAL FUNDING
FOR REGIONAL CENTERS IT'S
BECAUSE OF LIMITATIONS IN THE
FUNDING.
THAT WE'RE OF RESTRICTED IN
TERMS OF HIRING -- ADDITIONAL
STAFF WE'VE HEARD SOME.
INDIVIDUALS TALK ABOUT.
THE THE YOUNG BEING IN THE MAIN
PERSON CARING SEVEN TYPES OF
EXPERTISE FOR THE REGIONAL
CENTER.
I ADVOCATE FOR SERVICE
COORDINATION -- AND I ADVOCATE
FOR OUR SYSTEM AS A WHOLE.
BUT FOR SERVICE COORDINATION
I'VE BEEN WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTER FOR ELEVEN YEARS AND FOR
THE LAST NINE YEARS WE BENT OVER
OUR CASELOAD RATIOS.
AND CURRENTLY -- WE'RE WELL
WE'RE STILL UNDER THAT PLAN OF
CORRECTION WE HAVEN'T FAILED TO
MEET THAT AND WITHOUT HAVING
REASONABLE HE SLOWLY -- WE CAN'T --
DO THE ADEQUATE JOB THAT WE NEED
TO SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS TO BE
PRESENT TO BE ACCOUNTABLE TO BE
ASSESSABLE -- TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE'RE HERE TO
SERVE -- WE KNOW OUR GEOGRAPHIC
AREAS REALLY LARGE WE HAVE A LOT
OF WIND CHILL TIME -- FOR
SERVICE COORDINATION THEY AT ALL
TAKES AN IMPASSE -- RIGHT NOW
WE'RE ON A HIRING FREEZE SO WE
HAVE POSITIONS WE HAVE SERVICE
COORDINATORS WHO ARE CARING
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY CASES.
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T BEEN ALL
TOUGH FEEL -- BACK FEEL
POSITIONS BECAUSE OF OUR
OPERATIONS BUDGET.
SO I ASK -- AS YOU CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF OUR SYSTEM
AS A WHOLE ARE PROVIDERS THAT
YOU ALSO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
OPERATION SYSTEM FOR REGIONAL
CENTERS.
THANK YOU.
FINISH UP WITH THE DIRECTOR
AFTER THIS BE OUR LAST SPEAKER
SO I'M ONE OF THE MY AND YOU'LL
BE THE ANCHOR.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KAREN JACK A MINI
AMOR SEMI RETIRED RN.
LIFETIME HUMBLE COUNTY RESIDENT
AND IN HERE REALLY AS AN
INTERESTED CITIZEN [INAUDIBLE]
BECAUSE I I HAVE BEEN ATTACHED
TO SOME OF THESE PEOPLE OVER THE
YEARS AND IN DIFFERENT ROLES
THAT I'VE HAD.
I JUST FOUND.
IT IT BREAKS MY HEART TO THINK
THAT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AGENCIES WHO
HAVE GIVEN THEIR LIVES AND ARE
PROVIDING WHAT WE'VE BEEN
HEARING ALL DAY.
SOME WONDERFUL SERVICES.
HOWEVER TENUOUS THEY ARE.
AND MANY ARE NEEDING MORE MONEY.
FOR CONTINUING THEIR SERVICES.
I'M AN BEFORE US WE HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE THERE'S GOING TO
BE MONEY GOING AWAY.
AND THAT MEANS THAT THESE
CITIZENS WHO ARE SO WELL
DESERVED. TO HAVE.
THAT THEY NEED TO LIVE THE LIFE
THAT THEY WANT TO LEAVE.
COULD BE.
ALL THAT COULD BE DISAPPEARING
FOR THEM.
IF THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS AND I
THINK WE NEED TO THINK WE'LL
SERIOUSLY ABOUT.
HOW WE ARE AS COMMUNITY HAS?
I THINK WAS DOCTOR SMALLEY SAID
THAT FIGURES OUT WHAT HAS TO BE
DONE -- THE ONE SIZE FITS ALL
DOESN'T FIT INTO THAT MODEL
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU [INAUDIBLE]
CLOSE.
WITH YOUR PERMISSION.
I WANT TO READ A LETTER -- FROM
A PARENT WHO WAS NOT ABLE TO
ATTEND THE MEETING PLEASE DO ON
AND I HAVE -- SOME PACKETS OF
INFORMATION -- FROM HIM TO YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FRAZIER AND
WOOD AND ALL OTHERS PLUS.
PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU FOR THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING I REGRET I CAN'T COME TO
YOUR READER FROM MY HOME.
AN HOUR WEST OF YOU KAGA BUT A
DOCTOR BLOOMBERG'S REQUEST
EVERITT NEWSLETTER FOR HIM TO
READ.
I'M RETIRED RANCHER IN BUSINESS
HONOR AND MY YOUNGEST SON NOW
THIRTY FIVE HAS DOWN SYNDROME.
IS DEVELOPMENTALLY BUT NOT
INTELLECTUALLY DISABLED IN NEEDS
AND RECEIVE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
KAREN SUPERVISION.
BUT IN LATE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
OUR LIVES WERE SUDDENLY AND
SHOCKINGLY TURNED INSIDE OUT AND
UPSIDE DOWN.
WHEN ONCE TRUSTED CARE GIVER
TRIED TO SEDUCE MY EXTREMELY
NAIVE SON [INAUDIBLE]
HE WITH FOUR DIFFERENT VISUAL
AND VERBAL SEXUAL SKILLS DURING
THE OVERNIGHT SHIFT IN MY SON'S
ON HOME.
THEN HE TOLD MY SON IF YOU TOLD
ANYONE ABOUT IT I WILL HURT YOU.
SENATE IN WHAT LATER BECAME
TYPICAL TYPICAL ME TO FASHION
THE CRIMINALS EMPLOYER THE
REGIONAL CENTER VENDOR REFUSED
TO BELIEVE MY SON'S REPORTS OF
THE ASSAULTS.
BACKED UP THE CRIMINAL IN
TERMINATED SERVICE TO MY SON
WELL BY A LADY NUMEROUS REGIONAL
CENTER REGULATIONS.
THEN OUR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
FELL DOWN ON THE JOB GIVING US
THE SAME ROUTINE EXCUSES THEY
TYPICALLY GIVE RAPE VICTIMS AND
PROJECTS THANK YOU SEC WORRY I
SOON LEARNED. TO MAKE A LONG
STORY VERY SHORT WITH THE CIVIL
SUIT HE WENT TO MEDIATE IN AND
THE COMPANY SETTLED WITH AN
AMOUNT HIGH SIX FIGURES.
BUT CRIMINAL REMAINS FREE TO
RESPOND.
US DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
STATISTICS SHOW THE ASSAULT RATE
ON THE DISABLED IS OVER THREE
TIMES THAT.
OF THOSE ON THE NON DISABLED.
DOCTOR BLOOMBERG SAYS IT'S
ROUGHLY SEVEN TO TEN TIMES
HIGHER.
IN A TRAINER FOR CALIFORNIA
MENTORS BUT STATISTICS THAT
88299% OF DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ABUSE.
THIS COMMITTEE IS IN PART
CASPER'S REACHING OUT TO
CALIFORNIA'S ID DE COMMUNITY TO
LEARN ABOUT THE CHALLENGES OF
THE DISABILITIES FACE.
AND WHAT THE STATE CAN DO TO
BETTER SERVE THEM.
THE MOST IMPORTANT WAYS TO DO
THIS OUR TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THOUGH NEARLY ALL CARE GIVERS
ARE DEDICATED CARING COMPETENT
WILL.
CHANGE THE ABUSE AND NEGLECT OF
DEVELOPMENT ONLY AN INTELLECTUAL
DISABLED CITIZENS IS NONETHELESS
A WIDESPREAD PROBLEM.
ENSURE THAT ALL REGIONAL SOME
PERSONNEL VENDORS AND VENDORS
EMPLOYEES ARE THOROUGHLY TRAINED
IN PREVENTING RECOGNIZING AND
REPORTING NEGLECT ASSAULT AND
ABUSE.
TAKE EVERY POSSIBLE STEP TO
ENSURE THAT ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSONNEL DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
JUDGES AND COURT PERSONNEL ARE
THOROUGHLY TRAINED TO
INVESTIGATE PROSECUTE.
CONVICT CRIMINAL ABUSERS OF THE
DISABLED.
FEW IF ANY ARE ARRESTED CHARGED
OR CONVICTED.
PASS LEGISLATION REQUIRING JUST
XP COLLECTED ON THE DISPOSITION
OF EVERY REPORT OF ABUSE ASSAULT
ON THE COLLECT.
REGIONAL CENTERS COLLECT
STATISTICS ON THE REPORTS BUT
NOT ON THE OUTCOMES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO
THESE IMPORTANT MATTERS SHOW
AIRS.
MR ERRORS IS BEEN -- PRESENT AT
PRETTY MUCH ALL OF OUR ON YELP
EVERYWHERE ALL OF OUR BOARD.
MEETINGS ON ME AND HE IS
ADVOCATED -- AS A COMMUNITY
MEMBER WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
WITH THE JUDICIARY.
AND IN HIS PASSIONATE WORK.
ON BEHALF OF OF OUR CLIENTS --
HE'S HE'S BECOME A FRIEND -- THE
END I WANTED.
TO GIVE HIS HIS WORDS OF WHICH I
APPRECIATE YOU DOING SO USE OF
THANK YOU.
SOON THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING
HERE AND PARTICIPATING THIS
HEARING TODAY.
I LOVE MEETING ALL OF YOU.
LIKE TO SAY GOODBYE TO ALL BY
JUST SAYING THAT I'M VERY
GRATEFUL TO BE HERE TODAY.
THE SYSTEM HAS INJURED
FLUCTUATING LEVELS OF SUPPORT
FROM THE STE THE PAST DECADE
NASA OKAY WITH ME.
GET THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
WITH ADD CONTINUES TO RISE.
SO WE CONTINUE TO SERVICE PEOPLE
MORE PEOPLE WITH LESS.
AGAIN THAT'S NOT OKAY.
OVER THE LAST DECADE AT AN
AVERAGE INCREASE RATE OF OVER
THREE POINT 7% ANNUALLY WE'VE
SEEN ABOUT A HUNDRED NEW HUNDRED
THOUSAND NEW CONSUMERS ENTERING
INTO THE SYSTEM.
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND ARE NOW BEING
SERVICED AS WE SHOULD EXPECT TO
SEE MORE COMING IN.
AND I LIKED.
THE BOARD PRESIDENT'S COMMENT
ABOUT WHAT WE DO BUT EACH YEAR.
WE LIVE IN THE PAST.
AND I TOOK THAT TO HEART SIR.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN RECENT BUDGET
AUGMENTATIONS?
LIMITED AS THEY ARE TO THE
SYSTEM TO MEET NEEDS.
THIS IS THIS IS JUST A TEMPORARY
FIX [INAUDIBLE]
TO OUR LONG.
WE ALL THE SYSTEM [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
IN THIS MAY REVISE [INAUDIBLE]
NOT DONE.
WE STILL WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU.
ON A CONTINUAL BASIS AND THIS IS
IT WAS ABOUT TO BUILD A
RELATIONSHIP.
I'D LIKE TO I WOULD LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE SURVEY OF FAMILIES BEING
SERVICED BY THE SYSTEM.
FIND A LINK IN THIS TO THE
SURVEY.
ON THE ON THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON A LENT INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES.
WEBSITE AND LOOK FOR THE LINK AT
THE BOTTOM OF THE AGENDA.
WITH YOUR INPUT WE WILL LEARN
MORE ABOUT YOU AND YOUR NEEDS.
AND WE ARE ONLY STRONGER.
TOGETHER.
I AM PROUD OF YOUR COMMUNITY.
OF HOW YOU BAND TOGETHER
[INAUDIBLE]
IT'S NOT.
BEEN DONE. TO MY KNOWLEDGE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND HAVE
A SAFE TRIP HOME TODAY.
BUT I ALSO WANT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD WHO I ABSOLUTELY
APPRECIATE HIS.
COLLEGIAL NATURE IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND HIS PASSION FOR HIS
COMMUNITY. TO SAY A FEW WORDS IN
THIS CLOSING.
BUT WITH HIM WE WILL SUCCEED.
WAS WAS WAS A THANK YOU TO
EVERYTHING I I I WANTED JUST
TAKE THROUGH SOME THINGS THAT I
HEARD TODAY THAT -- SOME
SURPRISE ME AND SOME DON'T
BECAUSE I KNOW THE NATURE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
YEAH WE HEARD A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE HIGH RATES OF DUAL DIAGNOSIS
AND AND AND IT MAY BE MORE THAN
TO ABIDE OF SOME MAYBE THREE OR
FOUR DIAGNOSIS WITH SOME OF OUR
CLIENTS AND AND THAT THE
CHALLENGES THAT THAT THAT THAT
FACES.
WE ALSO HEARD THAT EARLY
INTERVENTION WORKS AND WE ARE
HEARING MORE AND MORE ABOUT
EARLY INTERVENTION -- IN OUR
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEES AS WE HEAR
OF PEOPLE COMING FOR TO TALK
ABOUT THAT IT WAS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL THAT WE GET.
THE RESOURCES AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE I'M A DENNIS BY
TRAINING THAT'S WHAT I DID FOR
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS AND I KNOW
THAT PREVENTION AND EARLY CARE
MAKE A HUGE AMOUNT OF DIFFERENCE.
AND ONE OF MY CONTINUAL
FRUSTRATIONS AT THE STATE IS WE
DON'T INVEST IN PROGRAMS.
LIKE WE SHOULD SO MANY TH
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE OUR
LINE ITEMS IN A BUDGET AND THAT
EVERY YEAR.
IF WE COULD INVEST IN AND
ACTUALLY MOVE FORWARD ON
PROGRAMMING WHETHER IT'S WHETHER
IT'S DIABETES PREVENTION OR THE
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY
OR ANY NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS.
THE OVERALL IMPACT OF THE
QUALITY OF LIFE AND PEOPLE'S.
OVERALL HEALTH -- THEIR OUTLOOK
ON ON THE FUTURE WOULD BE MUCH
MUCH DIFFERENT AND AND IS IT IS
A CONTINUAL SOURCE OF
FRUSTRATION TO ME THAT WE DON'T
WORK THAT WAY.
AND THAT WHY IT IS PARTICULARLY --
REWARDING TO BE WORKING WITH --
SOMEONE WHO SHARES THAT PASSION --
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY HAVE A HAVE
A HAVE A PARTNER IN IN SOME OF
THESE SOME OF THESE -- ENDEAVORS
AS WE GO FORWARD.
WELL WHEN I I'M REALLY GRATIFIED
FOR WAS IT HE GOT TO SEE THE
AMAZING STRENGTH IN UNITY OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND YOU DON'T SEE THAT IN A LOT
OF AREAS AND AND IT IS --
PARTICULAR HEARTENING TO ME WHEN
I COME TO OUR COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THIS THIS MASSIVE
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT.
THAT IT IS ONE OF THE HALLMARKS
OF RURAL CALIFORNIA IS IT WE
STICK TOGETHER BECAUSE WE HAVE.
TO BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
OUTSIDE RESOURCES BUT BY
STICKING TOGETHER WE PROVIDE A
QUALITY OF CARE FOR PEOPLE THAT
IS DIFFERENT.
AND BETTER I THINK THAN THAN A
LOT OF COMMUNITIES SO -- WE
HEARD ABOUT ASUS -- SOMETHING
THAT I'VE BEEN ACUTELY AWARE OF
THAT HUMBLE COUNTY HAS A IT HAS
THE HIGHEST RATE IN THE STATE IS
NOT JUST THE HIGHEST RATE IT'S
TWICE THE AVERAGE.
WE NOW HAVE A SURGEON GENERAL
APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR NEW SOME
THAT WILL ADDRESS.
SOME OF THAT SHE'S AN EXPERT IN
ACES AND MICHAEL WAS TO GET HER
UP.
AND TO MEET WITH.
FINALLY -- AND THE REASON I
ASKED ABOUT AUTONOMY IN THE
ABILITY FOR YOU TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES IN THE WAY THAT
OUR BEST.
IS THAT.
ANOTHER FRUSTRATION IS THAT AT
THE STATE WE DO A LOT OF ONE
SIZE FITS ALL THINGS.
AND YOU DON'T ALWAYS HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY WE NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN OUR IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THANK RURAL ALWAYS RULE IT IT'S
COST LESS TO LIVE OUT THERE ARE
ITS WHATEVER IT DOESN'T.
THE DISTANCES THAT WE HAVE TO
TRAVEL FOR SERVICES ARE MUCH
GREATER IT'S NOT AS NOT ONLY IS
A MUCH GREATER DISTANCE TAKES
LONGER SOMETIMES -- HEALTH CARE
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IS 30%
MORE EXPENSIVE THAN IT IS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA -- AND SO
WITH HEIGHT WITH GREATER
DISTANCES MORE FUEL CONSUMPTION
ALSO PAY MORE FOR GASOLINE ME
PAY MORE FOR A LOT OF THINGS.
THAT CONCEPT THAT SOMEHOW WELL
THERE RURAL COMMUNITY THEY DON'T
NEED AS MUCH IT'S JUST THE
OPPOSITE WE ACTUALLY OFTEN NEED
MORE.
AND SO AS LONG AS I'M IN THIS IN
THIS ROLE -- I'M GONNA CONTINUE
TO ADVOCATE HARD FOR RURAL
CALIFORNIA -- BIG SHOES TO FILL
WITH THE SENATOR CHESBRO AND
PATTY BERG WHO'VE BEEN STAUNCH
ADVOCATES HERE BUT THEY
RECOGNIZE THAT AND AND AS WELL
AND I WAS IS AN HONOR TO BE ABLE
TO FOLLOW THEM THERE SO.
I PARTICULARLY AM THRILLED TO
SEE THE COP THE COLLABORATION
AND THE AND AND A LOT FEWER
SILOS HERE THAN WE SEE AND IN
OTHER AREAS AND AND A FOCUS ON A
WHOLE PERSON CARE.
SIZE WAS A THANK YOU TO EVERYONE
WHO CAME OUT TODAY AND SHARED
WITH US -- YOUR STORIES YOUR
CONCERNS AND AND AND SHARED WITH
US WHAT'S GOING WELL AND IT WAS
IT WAS A GREAT EXPERIENCE FOR
FOR ME AND AND AND THIS KIND OF
COMMITTEE GIVES US THE
OPPORTUNITY TAKE BACK WHAT'S
WORKING WELL.
LEARN FROM WHAT ISN'T WORKING
WELL AND TRY TO COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS TO MAKE THINGS BETTER
FOR ALL OF US AS WELL THANK GOD
ONCE AGAIN.
A MISTER FRAZIER HIS STAFF ON
THE CITY EVERYONE WHO HELPED US
PUT THIS TOGETHER TODAY HAS BEEN
AN AMAZING EXPERIENCE.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOU
TO DISAPPEAR.
TODAY.
WITH YOU WE'RE NOT EXPERTS.
NOW YOU WHICH YES.
CAN SHARE THE INFORMATION.
THE TIME WITH US THAT WE CAN BE
OF SERVICE TO YOU.
AND MAKE.
PEOPLE THAT WE ALL CARE ABOUT
THEIR LIVES BETTER